[Music]
that's pretty good
we are so synced hello everybody and
welcome
yes February 17th it's Friday baby and
we are here for an after dark joined by
the beautiful talented
uh dedicated loving courageous Fearless
who is uh Shredder
he's been through so much and we love
him and heel is also here
oh they're excited
it's it's the Swaggy swaggiest slightest
um cardigan I've ever seen and I had to
get it what's the brand yeah what is it
British words Ms no gcds yeah what does
that stand for
something with God
so too many letters how do you even
remember that gcds yeah it's a cool
Brian
um GC yeah it sounds like a call letters
yes okay whatever I'm never going to
that website what does it stand for I
forgot
stupid ass name Gods can't destroy Gods
can't destroy that is so embarrassing
stop no it is it's embarrassing it's
unforgivable that that's their name well
that jacket rocks so yeah so wrong wrong
again Ethan that's like a 13 year old
gamer tag lethan
Gods can't destroy shut up
how much is the jacket that's
see that's the important detail tell me
about God's can't destroy it then
I don't want to say is it that bad yeah
we talking 5 000 or less no no my God so
more or less than a thousand yes that
was my question
more or less than two thousand
live no it's about a thousand okay okay
thousand okay yeah [__] them Gods can't
destroy this wallet
love it though I mean it looks expensive
the details are crazy it's amazing it's
a work of art
even Gods can't destroy it I heard
thank you welcome everybody
um today's episode is episode today's
episode is sponsored by honey and Native
who we love so dang well
wait it me it stands for Gods can't
destroy streetwear
is it okay I wasn't sure well maybe just
said yes I mean that that's what I'm
saying I don't know there's a there's
another brand with the same but it's not
uh God can't destroy in there so gcds
gcd's nuts
yes sir wow I hope they're watching
actually speaking of good clothing
brands we have a little bit of a secret
sale going on
uh don't tell anyone at teddyfresh.com
it is kind of a secret
shh
[Laughter]
except for this huge Banner on the what
on the website I this wasn't here
yesterday it was so secretive maybe less
Secret
if you go to last chance this is
basically I'll tell you guys
we have a ton of really nice stuff left
and kind of there's a lot of weird sizes
there's a few different sizes yeah
definitely
so we've got like you know
sizes of this and that all crazy so but
you know it's kind of the last chance as
they say well you know you guys know
you've seen those cells where it's like
last chance oh my God it's like 60 off
but it's only one size well actually
it's up to 80 off some of this [__] we
did deep deep discounts because like
we just want to get you know it's like
okay we have like 10 4xls
um
but it's a good opportunity right ELO
hell yeah oh this one already sold out
um go to teddyfresh.com well just go to
the link and click the or good [__] you
guys know how to get here
um there's all kinds of cool stuff Rick
and Morty sorry guys I just it's a heavy
discount
I mean I paid for the product I got to
unload it
right is that a heavy heavy discount
though
the show's continuing on you know right
yeah he's not associated anymore no not
at all right
I don't know who's going to want to wear
it
that's the problem fans of the show
I don't know that you can wear Rick and
Morty stuff out in public anymore can
you
this is a great sales this is such a
great commercial yeah I'm just being
real well that's why it's so heavily
discounted this is 18.
I want to talk to the show manager after
this show because I might I might need
like a m a good yeah I'll make good on
this one I'll make good you don't worry
here
it's gonna be rare now that's what I was
gonna say it's the collectible that's a
fair it's a collector's item
that's a fair point kind of like uh the
Cosby dolls uh-huh sure just well yeah
these amount of similarities Harvey
Weinstein had a apple cider actually
it's super coveted
I mean it is cool stuff though like you
know what I mean heavily discounted did
I mentioned heavily discounted
so
the quality is great like maybe just
don't leave the house in it
could sleep in it sleep in it 2018 bucks
22 bucks it's 30. 38 bucks and this was
like super high quality stuff so this
isn't my first road sleep in it that
hoodie is so nice can you click on it
snowball one yeah click on it let's look
at the close-up of that yeah not super
there's a close-up is this oh there's
like more down here
that is super clean bro see that that's
an applique and embroidery that is
insanely clean yeah but just it's nice
but don't leave the house with it
the liability nobody would know that
that's from that show right
kind of snowball it's kind of generic I
wouldn't risk it don't leave the house
in this stuff you guys
yeah so that's my sales pitch
any other uh stuff you need to not leave
the house in on here no just that no the
rest are good
yeah just that go check it out you know
there's all kinds of fun stuff here you
might get find the size that you like
and a fat heavy discount
and it's a small risk of being
associated with uh
horrible horrible day next time I'm
gonna give you a copy read yeah
that doesn't have to be a good idea all
right yeah
the sponsors should be happy I do it to
my own brand too you know what I mean I
just got to keep it 100 all the time
it's my flaw it's my flaw I just I'm so
honest and I am so Frank
that honestly
honestly yeah so um anyways thank you
thank you peace and love peace
oh look who's here it's Gabe
all right
Gabriel is your full name Gabriel
[Applause]
I do it
is your full name Gabriel
my full name is white cloud gate oh oh
right of course
so Gabe is your last name actually
oh yeah
what you doing you're waiting for the
bus
this year it's the year I tried my first
things baby
so wait my first time oh my first time
I'm gonna try coffee baby this is my
first time
before you try that let's unpack it
you've never tried coffee in your 50
years of life yeah
nah what so he's never had he's never
had sex and he's never drinking coffee
maybe one is a gateway to the other
sure
I have like coffee in my veins you know
how like body is made of 90 water mine
is like coffee
actually all baddies they say have 90
coffee in their veins Gabe your thoughts
yeah we get some coffees please don't
talk about coffee okay but hold on
because your buddy Nick there or nephew
but you're gonna drink it dark that's
what I'm saying he's doing you dirty by
giving you just black that's like the
hardcore way to start yeah what's up
Nick Nick what's going on here
he can't hear me probably huh all right
give it a shot let's see what you think
all right
Gabe's first taste of coffee ever
he's splashing it around
oh my God wait can you try another one
that wasn't fair yeah something with
like cream in it some sugar something
tasty all right let's try this is my
first time you should get a frappuccino
have you ever had a frappuccino my dude
can you ask Nick Nick say let's I want
you to go get a frappuccino yeah and
call us back is that possible are you
guys outside a coffee store
we're outside a copy store I think of a
frappuccino tell Nick what I said
Gino
cappuccino because it's sweet yeah yeah
I I didn't like it this is my first time
I said I didn't like it right no I got
that but yeah I want you to try the
Frappuccino and see if you like it
because yeah straight black coffee is
not very good I don't like it either
that's so hardcore that's like after 30
years of drinking coffee that's what you
drink yeah yeah so are you open to
getting a Frappuccino or
what do you think Frappuccino yeah
okay okay I can join you I can I can
join you okay that's fun okay cool great
oh Gabe with the essentials again dude
he's hyper [__] though you don't
understand Gabe does Gabe does figures
you know what I mean yeah he doesn't
remember this guy is clocking major
numbers yeah look how he walks around he
has swag yeah actually is that a Gabe is
that a scar on the back of your head or
a flavor uh a little bit of flavor flare
flavors yeah so what you want to ask for
Gabe is a Frappuccino with with whipped
cream on top okay mocha mocha
Frappuccino
do you like I would try do you like
chocolate Gabe Tom mocha Frappuccino
with whipped cream
do you like chocolate Gabe
yeah
so the mocha Frappuccino
I think we're gonna have a hit here
okay
okay fit check
um
maybe just one do you need help what did
he ask what did he ask Gabe wait what
did he ask you yes what um how many pops
it's one time
of the sweetener yeah
the bare minimum that's all you need for
Christ
yeah yeah that's perfect ask it oh
careful the car yeah okay it's not
legible but Gabe coverage is a card uh
numbers but it's not legible but yeah
there you go you're okay good man yeah
okay
all right so we got the mocha frap
this is coming right up awesome this is
exciting man this is right up I love
this I think you're gonna like this I
you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
while we wait you got any plans this
weekend
[Music]
well just taking it easy this weekend
really yeah
nothing specific just relaxing
easy it's probably tequila not take it
easy
don't you think for someone that drinks
a lot of alcohol
I find it interesting that coffee was so
unpalatable to you that you spit it out
some people would say alcohol doesn't
taste good either yeah
yeah they put sweetener in it it
probably would tastes better yeah that's
right that's something that caffeine
that sometimes somehow make you nauseous
and stuff right right good good awesome
Kim how did Valentine's go oh did you
have a nice Valentine's Day you were
gonna have a date with that lovely girl
you were you were uh courting recording
yes yeah well we're just taking it easy
go on okay now we got the mocha frappe
oh that was quick
shout out
oh yeah let me get a look at that let me
get a look at that that's now that's a
breath
that is level one give that a hit give
add a little smack on your lips that
introduction to Coffee you're right wrap
your lips around that
that's a long step what do we think now
this is much better
Frappuccino
that's good
the mocha rapid it's going to give you a
nice boost too huh oh yeah especially if
you've never drinking calf caffeine or
coffee yeah this is gonna so send you
out of a rocket ship
yeah
so uh tell me uh what did you guys do on
Valentine's Day you just hung out did
you go out to dinner I know last time we
spoke you were shopping for a gift
yeah I would just hang out you just hung
out where
are you at the mall or something oh was
it at the mall or because you
something simple like the mall had like
a little you know lunch and stuff that's
about it okay okay nice where did you
guys eat
we got that the the mall the mall Cafe I
guess okay that's nice yeah that's
awesome yeah and and did you guys have
good chemistry was that what did it go
off well
um it's it's just a star it's just
building the basics yeah yeah taking it
easy that's right we're just going to
build a foundation the essentials that's
smart the essential take it slow take it
nice don't push yeah she's got to be
impressed though because I mean you are
a very successful individual you have
money you have a great job and you are
kind of famous so that's got those are
big big and also you're sweet look at
that smile and you slay
so
she's got to be impressed by that stuff
don't you think
oh yeah yeah
he likes that prep
so will there be a second date meeting
we'll see it's kind of like the
interview of dates like do you want to
go for a job interview if they like you
then go to second base true let me ask
you this are you going to ask her
on a second date
we'll see
[Laughter]
let me ask you even more questions
what is it about her that you're waiting
to see you're unsure about your feelings
for her
I love her very much she's very
understanding and I I wanna I want her
to feel comfortable with you know I want
I want to express my I want her to feel
comfortable with me before I express my
feelings you know like I could turn my
thoughts and stuff yeah you're a good
man playing it well you're playing
you're doing all the right things here
yeah you're a good man dude she's a
lucky girl I hope it works out I hope it
works out yeah yeah
mm-hmm
cool
eat my [__] from the necklace
have you asked her that yet
smoother than that maybe third day maybe
that's a third day thing
okay okay
laughs
I'm not into that yet that's like way
way yeah far down the road
yeah you got to take your time sometimes
you know what I mean
get some of this coffee too
oh
that's good right oh yeah that's good
you hit that
let's see how it does hopefully
hopefully what
I'll play well it won't make me get sick
or anything I try to do alcohols and
stuff some are good some if it's if it
doesn't give the good mix I get sick
it's just coffee I doubt it because you
you're drinking caffeines and a lot of
stuff you know you'll be fine Coke ice
tea exactly yeah
[Music]
do you have a problem with dairy stuff
no I love Dairy I don't think Dairy
hurts me there you go all right
what's funny
I don't know I'm just smiling yeah it's
a nice day it is actually really nice
it's beautiful to say yeah
mm-hmm
what's going on thank you not much just
doing a podcast
I started drinking the H3 copy what kind
of copy is that this is just black
coffee with cream in it oh okay how is
it to you it's nice the cream helps a
lot you'd be surprised and really oh
okay yeah
okay let's get it
yeah we're just doing a podcast
afternoon me and my homies
you know
all right Gabe listen I love you bud
good luck okay if you need advice ask me
ask Nick to go he's a Mac that guy knows
is that guy knows you know what to do
he's kind of like my I don't like my
producer my
Creator all right [__] baby [__] [__]
[__] [__] yeah I said who the [__] is
okay who the [__] is okay
love you bud whoa you just said a crazy
magic trick
please do that all right take care bud
love you
[Applause]
I could love checking in on Gabe you
know that was pretty special
um
the moat we got him on the mocha Nick
did him so dirty with that yeah
I love that though the next time he's a
wheel I like the idea of him trying
first next time we'll have him on
shrooms and oh the first it's my first
time trying to fly that'll be good
that'll be good that's a great idea
that'll be good oh this is good so Gabe
is actually giving Alpha energy with the
we'll see
what a legend
I love that good for him so anyway
um right at the top here you guys know I
have a obviously the title that's
acknowledged the third baby thing yeah
talk about that in a little bit there's
some stuff at the top of the show I want
to look at but yeah we're doing it third
baby time baby
watch out the clients are coming we re
we're repopulating this [__] watch out
Elon Musk Nick Cannon watch out Nick
Cannon
Ethan on Wednesday you said that Puerto
Ricans aren't your demo I didn't say
that
there's one
here's one thank you first of all Sphinx
at men appreciate that very much
when the when did I say Puerto Ricans
aren't my demo
I love what Toby I don't remember
I don't know I'm thinking about moving
there 50 times 50 of the year so I don't
have to pay taxes anymore
I love throwing paper towels to my
Puerto Rican Neighbors
yes anybody that will be willing to put
this show on and sit through it
it's just a legend no matter where
they're from
the harder to explain it is to someone
who walks in on you the better the shows
are in my opinion
you know like I saw comments we did our
McDonald's bit yes and I saw people in
those comments they're like I was
laughing at myself at this man sitting
silently eating McDonald's for like 10
minutes and people were asking what the
[__] was so funny about it you can't
explain it you can't explain it you
possibly couldn't
but uh there it is okay so before we get
into that Jay Shetty you guys know he's
my arch nemesis it goes cab and then it
goes Jay Shetty right the reason I
[__] hate this guy
oh this by the real fast yeah this
uh yeah and then he literally streamed
an entire segment if he needed
McDonald's just in front of a Green
Street and that actual McDonald's what
podcast has the balls to do that that's
exactly what I'm saying bro nobody
nobody
I went home that day Neila said how's
the show I said it was good we did four
hours one hour of it was me sitting
silently eating McDonald's yeah like
fire show and I was like what do you
mean and it's like yeah you were sitting
silently eating McDonald's
yes so Jay Shetty he has a podcast
apparently I never [__] heard of him
only Sam apparently is the only person
in the world that listens
she loves him who is Tim who is Sam
she's listening to his podcast actually
yeah she's right now
yourself when I find out she's a
[__]
so so here's your idea Shetty she
started running back
you just [__] in your pants Sam I just
shut myself listening to you say Jay
Shetty all right well here's your Idol
Sam and all you [__] out there this
guy continually beats me yeah in the
streamy awards okay nominated five times
we've been nominated five right right
take all the glory and this [__] guy
beats us he has a podcast only a
Facebook only podcast where he go oh
motivational shut up dude
this man just dropped a 20 smoothie and
Erawan the the market that everybody in
the world laughs out because it's the
most expensive Market in the world you
buy like a carton of milk for fifty
dollars there because the because like
the cow's Teddy got spree sucked hey
everyone it's Jay Shetty I'm here
the stuff there is good but everybody
knows it yeah the cauliflower I will I
will splurge on if if I'm feeling it how
much are we talking about it's like a
food I mean yeah it's a hot bar but like
a side of cauliflower shouldn't really
be like 15 bucks
it's almost like obscene because it's in
Pacific Palisades or I don't know
there's one on Beverly yeah so the one
that I've only been to is in Pacific
Palisades it's the richest [__] place
you've ever been to you walk around
outside and it's like um the first time
I was there I was like oh this is what
white privilege this looks like it's a
place right there it looks it reminds me
of like uh The Truman Show that's like
what it's like there
um the prettiest people ever just like
walking up and down the aisles yes
everybody like just finished exercising
and she looks like perfect oiled up yeah
I don't even and I have to say this the
whitest [__] place you've ever been
yes it is white it looks like Fox News
anchors only
and uh so the inside this little spot is
Arrow one and it's almost like a flaunt
it's like stupid like everybody knows
you're paying too much just because you
don't care about money it's like it's
like Olivia said 15 for a side of
cauliflower it's [__] silly
so of course Jay Shetty the
inspirational speaker is doing a collab
with heroine yeah you guys think he's a
man whatever right see I don't even know
how to say it I'm such an assault of the
earth everyone
and so this guy is apparently he's
trying to pretend like he's one of you
[Laughter]
this is the difference between [__] and
me play that again Zach
I guess even they know about it in China
that's true he's always talking about
money that's why he has all that money
look at this [__] 20 1918.
or it's just these two wait is that him
too
I think he won a different cat the
health and wellness well who's he
[__] sucking off dude I'm sorry on
purpose yeah I know
and so this man is trying to appear to
be a man of the people he's here to
motivate you okay yeah motivate me to go
spend 20 on a smoothie motivated these
notes that's what
uh what's next Jay Shetty you'll be
you'll be avocado toast
yeah I care about my fans all right so
here's his [__] smoothie we have it
by the way we're gonna oh okay we bought
two three of those we bought three
smoothies
for today
it was a bonus
smoothies so we got three folks so
excluding that what was the fourth one
Haley Bieber yeah oh she's got a
smoothie too yeah how much was hers
probably the same same price 20 bucks so
this is like some goofy line hey y'all
want to do a smoothie with us you're
gonna make like 13 per smoothie you're
like wow that's a great margin it does a
blended fruit
a lot of [__] you have not seen this
smoothie yet and I gotta tell you I
watched it before the show yeah I'm a
little bit of a [__] but I don't
give a [__] with a little bit of a
[__] no I'm almost here you almost
shot yourself I'm I saw this smoothie
this morning and I was like
you guys that looks good sure yeah it
should yeah I'm sure it looks good can
we watch the video I mean at what point
is it too expensive no you're not done
so we bought three smoothies so that's
60 plus tax so you're looking at almost
70 [__] dollars for three smoothies
you guys yeah that's mental let's watch
hey everyone it's Jay Shetty I'm here so
far one and I'm about to make my love
potion it's out 14th of February what
did you come in it you weirdo I mean
Siri why is he calling This Love Potion
he's weird for Valentine's Day
yeah and he came in it probably that's
why I mean I'm not saying he takes a lot
of effort to produce something as jizz
rise and grind mindset dude
oh take off the flannel like you're a
man of the people
whether you're in a relationship this is
what you need to drink I'm about to make
it so we're gonna start off with some
oat milk how are you gonna milk a note
oh we supposedly made that in there
we've got some strawberries
okay okay got some raspberries okay pick
that up dude the [__] I've got a banana
hey bro you just broke [__] on the floor
like who does that I think it was a
mistake I know but if you drop something
especially okay well they're recording
your videos well it's gonna pick it up I
think it's in the kitchen I don't think
it's a public
thinking about Jay Shetty right now
milk strawberries raspberries bananas
what are you cool make that at home
you're like you're at three bucks right
now okay well and pick the raspberry up
off the floor while you're at it please
Jay it's [__] up okay what else you're
a God you think you're so much better
than everyone
got some Rose this this is gonna give it
that extra special oh roll a rose then
we've got avocado
okay everyone knows what this is
especially no tell me tell me what
avocado is
don't make assumptions you're supposed
to be a motivational speaker assumptions
make asses of you and me Jay Shetty [__]
you
let me tell you about it
that's what this is beets
it's just for the color
and then we've got our joyo unsweetened
black tea
for that special taste
same yo let let the man cook let them
cook let him cook let them cook I'm
watching it I'm just cooking started to
get more interesting as we added more
things in too much [__] in there Mike
maybe maybe
avocado
we got some of that Moon Juice sex dust
shut up dude why sex stuff but now he's
drying out his Sun drying his semen and
putting it into that that's horrific
that's disgusting
semen dust
[__] you
oh Sarah
I don't know what that's a lot man we've
got this 11 11 adaptogenic mushrooms
what what
this is some potion [__] this is
like something
you know what I mean probably won't
affect the taste too much though so I
don't need maybe cheers in my skin
what does it do what is this tinctured
what did he say it was again mushrooms
there was a specific type of mushroom
yeah maybe it's very healthy yeah I'm
sure it is why does it lie here good
here it is Dan it's the maple syrup
maple syrup such a sucker and then we've
got this 11 11 adaptogenic mushrooms
that's made up
[__]
oh [__] 7-Eleven super multi-mushroom
Synergy okay it is yeah right and that
that's right next to Alpha Brain on the
blend of 11 powerful impotent potent
functional mushrooms
like a multivitamin that's [__]
literally why don't you put some Alpha
well it says it's good for immune health
antioxidant and energy and resilience
and were those statements uh uh uh
assessed by the FDA in any way
um
it doesn't say which makes me lean
towards no you want to know what's my
love potion [__] gamer sup bro that's
true pour some powder it's got caffeine
take it down all right and it costs like
30 cents per drink because I'm real like
that and I should be winning these
streamies
there we go
like one drop of something that's gonna
anything no and then we've got lacuma
stop with the things that go in there
it's just random [__] and almond
butter
obviously the last one chooses not to
come out it's butter bro you clearly
never made this
oh the almond butter won't come out yeah
it's very viscous bro you know anything
about cooking
clearly doesn't anything about life
well I don't even get to see him try it
he's not eating that [__] someone said
whoever's doing the pr for Jason is
killing it right now until I came
so this person made a joke it's 29 nine
dollars plus tax not that far off Jamie
so let's bring it out here we go all
right Jay shetty's Miracle love smoothie
I think it settled a little bit maybe
Shake It Up
give it a fair shot so they so they
actually have it oh it's supposed to be
like that I take it back
so this is pretty heavy
[Music]
that is heavy so it's not bottled it's
like fresh from Arrow on yeah so this is
probably a paid sponsorship they paid
him to do this because this is on their
social media site and he clearly he
doesn't know anything about cookies he
might he might
the man doesn't know almond butter is
not runny Dan
everyone does different smoothies with
different celebs like Kourtney
Kardashian at the black and white one
that's it and then Haley Bieber had the
strawberry glaze they paid them all I
don't know if there were more but this
is I know about that are you gonna milk
a note I don't know liver King are you
ready for the shitty Shake
[Music]
it's not that good I tell you he put the
rose extract in there because he wanted
to be different and it's just it's not
the vibe
there's too much [__] in there it's a
Vibe right now
it almost doesn't take taste like much
in the end like there's so much in there
I just taste like the rose actually it
doesn't be jerky
it's like perfumey yeah it is perfume oh
it's very perfumey
did you try it Dan no I haven't tried it
okay well then what then to try it if I
want to start Aiden so your mouth was
about to open and hate was gonna come
out
I'm into 20 smoothie I'm gonna drink it
pretty good actually if it was five
bucks I'd be like that's that's pretty
interesting oh here we go okay I got a
little is it sweet yes it's sweet yeah
but not too sweet okay
[Music]
oh that's good what the [__] are you
talking about it's fine yeah it's good
that's great
it's good is it twenty dollars yo
so that's one of the best shakes I've
ever had or smoothies or whatever
would you pay twenty dollars plus tax
for them
no but it's good okay I'm a [__] I'm
saying it I'm coming out of the closet
his eyes are beautiful
I do think that it's really pretty with
the smooth color accent it's not like
some bitter [__] in it
that's not good beats dude who would pay
twenty dollars for this thank you you go
to Baskin Robbins get a five dollar
Shake exactly you know what tastes good
a [__] chocolate milkshake okay it's
not about Flavor it's about that old
experience the only reason this guy is
successful because he has like beautiful
eyes well if this man had Brown he
doesn't know the struggle that I have as
a brown-eyed man
I just tasted it that is literally
delicious
I'm with Sam I like it really good it's
not worth the money but of course it's
fine it needs to be good yeah it's
better than fine though it's okay what
if it's 100 bucks you're still gonna sit
there oh yeah it's great I told you I
wouldn't well the price doesn't affect
the taste the reason why of course it's
gonna be good it's a 20 smooth you said
it wasn't that good
the reason why it costs so much is all
the supplements
probably yeah
bitter in here though what's the little
I like the little yeah
nice what is this cacao oh cacao cacao
it's like chocolate Crunch too yeah I
know it could go
not technically I feel like the sex dust
alone adds ten dollars to this you know
yeah if you want to get horny try Jay
Shetty Shake oh here's someone's trying
to defend him I I want to say that I do
make these at home and it's so easy to
make so it tastes pretty similar just
make your own at home without the rose
extract he's like oh put some Rose in
there okay dude I thought the rose that
was one of the only ingredients that
made me raise an eyebrow when I saw him
putting it in
I think it's subtle enough that it's a
nice a nice little touch it's better
than the average smoothie I'd say
better than some Jamba [__] better than
Jamba yeah oh yeah jamba's is not good
actually yeah
that's not let's not it's always too icy
and thick and then it never drinks right
mm-hmm disagree I'm not a huge fan of a
Jamba
right it's the biggest trick in there
yeah now that you said that that the
consistency and texture is actually
really good so that's another good point
for me it is yeah it drinks really good
you know what
and it's great I think I might start
watching this podcast after this yeah
what kind of stuff does he talk about go
ahead and probably talks about Alpha
Brain mushroom extract sex dust having
beautiful what's it like having
beautiful eyes
mm-hmm
I heard he got a surgery there's some
crazy surgery that you could get to make
your eyes blue you dare you put contacts
in no you can actually remove the
pigment in your eye with laser no Google
Blind like a year later yeah swear to
God there is it's illegal in the U.S
because it's so dangerous oh my God you
could go to like Russia or
there's other in Mexico they do it and
you'll have blue eyes for like a couple
years but you'll literally go blind
check that out it's awesome
that's cool
this is his wife oh they both have
beautiful eyes
wow
remember the same eyes it's interesting
yeah maybe they both got this are they
where did they find each other in iBook
I date they both got the surgery room
definitely
people would think I'm dead serious when
I say this so I'm not even joking
people would think I was so interesting
if I had eyes like that I swear to you
hmm
people be more forgiving or would never
love sponsors blue eye privilege I'm
serious it's not even blue eyes it's
like beautiful eyes with like dark ring
to the iris
gorgeous eyes like stunning you love him
yeah are you shouting yourself right now
yeah a little bit shetty's hot what can
you say yeah it's hot
TI's wife uh tiny got the surgery I'm
seeing a lot of people in chat match and
I remember that now wait who did uh TI's
wife Tiny who's tiny his wife
his wife got this surgery not for real
yeah she did
what I was joking she actually got that
[__] yeah it's permanent though it's not
time for the one the one that she got's
permanent no I know it's permanent but I
thought it was so dangerous
wait she went and got the fake eyes
they're so shallow
do you see how shallow they are what are
we talking about his wife got the eye
surgery don't shut these wipers oh who
did
TPI the rapper a TI so let me see her
eyes I want to see why are you worried
about my wife tip
look at this eyes
let me see TI's wife
TI wife eyes I mean why is the after
picture like the lowest resolution photo
so yeah pull that up
here
here I got it that one's also so before
and after
so you can do this but the risk is
insane like um huh
they like blast oh here we go
she doesn't have shitty eyes but they're
nice they're just blue they're like
plain blue that's crazy I didn't know
you could do that yeah
but she will go blind like it's almost
guaranteed wow that's just love of the
game right there and she understands the
power that those kind of eyes have she's
like I'd rather be blue-eyed for two
years than see it all
that's the game
yeah do you see the risk associated with
the DB
you know who else had eye surgery
less Legend
gorgeous eyes
um
[Music]
I was upset that we couldn't listen to
his other numbers and also the full
chestnuts on I saw a lot of people in
the suburbs saying I'm so over the
chestnut song not because I was offended
because it's not funny so what I did
as I told the guys go get every a Nook
song you can find and run it through
advanced AI software to isolate his
vocals so that we can listen to all his
full songs on the show anytime we want
go ahead Zach almost
[Music]
oh I know what song it is
to the place
I love West Virginia
I love this song play me the um I think
his voice is lovely when you isolate it
you can hear he
he can sing I agree he the man hits it
it's just there's just uh he has a how
do you say je ne saitwa a certain
as the French say wait what does that
mean it's a French expression he's got a
certain something it's an X Factor he's
got the X Factor yeah
okay now I'm getting chunks of like
that's what I was saying that's the
cocoa oh God
you're wrong Ethan about what
this guy is following him I do not like
that
I don't like my old
because you make my the whites my eyes
too bright I look like I literally took
a photo of Jay Shetty and then put his
eyes
look right well they're also like
slightly off too do it where it looks
more realistic I want to know what I
look like and you all be enchanted I
guarantee it looks like um uh
coincidence guy no such thing yeah all
right you're drinking that smoothie
pretty quick dude it's almost gone it's
good I agree it's good it's not 25 out
with tax good that's an insult to this
it's a separate conversations I will say
the chunks of cocoa but that's just the
store you know I think that there's
nothing to hate here actually all
different flavors they're all against me
next thing I'm going to come home either
is going to have the head I don't love
the the whole potions and the sex dust
and all that stuff I agree with you
there
pushing it a little a little try too
hard can jack can you play um
wait we have to do our ad that was what
I was trying to say before we got real
quick before we do that there was the
what we are the people in the world or
We Are the World
will be here together
to lie
the noise
[Laughter]
we were having so much fun with that
before the show because we were oh my
God we were lining it up with the actual
song and cutting him in and out like
they do in the original they were doing
it was [__] amazing dude this one's
still I think the white is too
it's too white like if you compare it
I don't agree I think that looks you
think that's right on the money yeah I
don't like him
so you take it back you stick it with
the brown eyes
you know we could get have you ever put
in contacts can you do that you get you
colored contacts and test it on the show
that episode yeah yeah let's do that
I'll order some right now we'll see get
me really nice ones yeah I'll get lost
behind my eyeball or some [__] I'm gonna
say make sure you go to legit site
nah I know a place down the street from
here I know but a lot of the first like
my sister got one of the first Google
results and it like [__] up her cornea
oh wait oh my god oh yeah get don't get
me one of those all right yeah wait this
is Hallie Bieber's we forgot to ask
Haley Bieber Holly whatever
has it
that's Haley Berry's uh
somebody in chat said what's the real
price I am not kidding you it is twenty
dollars yeah that was plus tax that's
not a meme it was it's a 20 uh smoothie
all right so this place is horribly
overpriced but
still tastes good if you go into arawan
and you get a cart
that's wealth that's wealth like if you
need a shopping cart in that place
that's old money right there
I'll say
Shady smoothie is way better okay
in the world of twenty dollars
I disagree man oh yeah why does that I
don't like that one
I don't like this one I think this one's
way better
you're really sweet it feels like it's
too sweet and weird I like sheddies
better that is way better I don't hate
it but shetty's had a really nice
texture yeah this one this one is a
Jamba Juice like the coconutty the
creamy
I can replicate it I think I think what
I like about this is I can taste the
horny goat weed yeah
no that really that adds a lot I can
taste the um St John's toe
I don't know what this shit's called St
John's Wort what is that
some there's some saints wart I forget
which Saint it was there's actually yeah
St John's Wort I'm like okay sounds good
what is it St John
it's really St John's Wort yeah why the
who the [__] named that
she turns me off why his wart
uh maybe is wart like an archaic name
for a type of plant or something oh it's
a it's hyphenated John's Wort
the Day of Reckoning will come
yeah apparently it's like uh has
antidepressants effects according to
pseudo-scientific people so I put a
little that in mind put some horny goat
weed which is also a real name of a
supplement you guys think I'm kidding
I'm not
it's literally called horny goat weed
Ronnie uh from Stern takes up [__] like
every day and it's supposed to make you
horny apparently so I'm gonna put some
horny goat weed in there
is there any other facility named
supplements I can get in there
uh Kayano Reeves uh [__] nipple milk
oh that
dandelions uh
dandelions uh carpet munching muffer
schmutzer
a little of that sure
there it is thank you
and of course some magic mushroom
all right let's show our sponsors
[Music]
oh is that a new one
today we thank our wonderful sponsors
who make this show possible
first we'd like to thank honey
[Music]
who doesn't love funny friends
you know what I mean you've had a big
old saving over the week I sent you one
recently right then yes I was at the
table Yeah okay 150 bucks I bought a
table literally did not expect this um
coupon at the end like seriously
straight up 150 back in your pocket yeah
that's the power of honey it's free
it's super easy to install you don't
even have to think about it and thanks
to them searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past it automatically
scours the internet for the best free
coupon code and automatically applies it
at checkout these are all genuine
savings that we in this studio have
shared in
and we just keep saving them it's crazy
if you're on the internet without honey
you've lost your mind
um it doesn't just work on the uh the
desktops either actually it works on
your iPhone too now just activate it on
Safari on your phone and save on the go
love it man you all really need to get
this if you don't already have honey you
could be straight up missing out and by
getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show which I
love and things so get PayPal honey for
free at joyhoney.com after dark that's
joinhoney.com after dark thank you
to honey
for making the show what it is and
giving us the budget to spend a hundred
dollars on smoothies on smoothies do you
understand like we we on these four
smoothies we literally spent a hundred
dollars including cash I do realize that
yeah that's [__] insane it's a bit
much if you go with a family
you have two kids and you go to the
grocery say hey who wants a smoothie
okay yeah a hundred dollars out the door
you can't do that no can't do that Jay
said he's supporting um
I can't get behind him
if anyone's dropping 20 bucks on a kid
to drink this smoothie and that kid's
just gonna sip on it and not like it as
much as Jamba Juice unfair he'll
probably win you know I mean literally
they would much rather take a milkshake
you know what's crazy about kids when I
was um we have another sponsor but now
I'm just kidding
something struck me I used to work in
like a fancy restaurant back in Santa
Cruz I was a waiter there
and they had this wonderful filet mignon
dish
it was like 40 bucks I could at the time
I couldn't even dream of spending that
much on on a dish
that really beautiful sauce mashed
potatoes
and this happened a few times
they would order that dish for like
their five-year-old's child and it would
be untouched
and they would leave it there untouched
and to me at the time I was like this is
they must be gajillionaires they must be
like billionaires to be able to not care
that they got a forty dollar filet
mignon for their kid and he didn't even
[__] touch it I'm not touching this
one man
I thought you were gonna say that you
would eat it I would oh yeah I did it I
did that definitely yeah well so so
usually it had like one bite and so I
would just cut that off and I'll eat it
yeah yeah and also it's just a waste
it's okay might as well I dream of being
able to afford that [__]
you know
crazy huh
anyway
oh yeah so here's one that I really love
you guys are gonna love this everyone in
the office is legitimately a huge fan
of native
what is native
they make
delicious smelling
aluminum free deodorant
they also keep their ingredients list
bare naked with ingredients you
understand like coconut oil shea butter
and baking soda
they have a bunch of products this they
want us to talk about their deodorant
but their whole line is insane I like uh
how many of y'all actually just using
native like
yeah and Sam you said you're using their
shampoo
uh she's like you just walked out but I
believe so yes I also use a shampoo and
conditioner really yeah is that great
yeah no it's [__] amazing the scents
are awesome and you get luscious locks
two of you guys just had it on you or
you had it on you right baby yeah yeah
you guys don't leave home without it or
what sometimes you just need to touch up
actually you have one here in the office
and I went at home and I keep one in my
gym bag
oh you go to the gym after work are you
in uh before work really
what are you what what are you working
on
you know my body
and my odors
really stinking up the place you know
that's weird I would never expect that
he goes to the gym because he always
smells so good when he walks in here
because he's so true
yeah no must are you trying to bulk up
Ian are you trying to like like does it
be healthy yeah just be healthy yeah
yeah
general maintenance how often do you go
four times a week wow really
you feel good you feeling good how long
you've been doing that
I'm feeling okay could use some more
Jace Shetty smoothies though yeah that
would Mark Jay Shetty inspiration yeah
but yeah sorry I wish I was Jay Shetty
for you Ian but I'm not just Ethan Klein
we'll get you the serial loser the Jay
Shetty don't worry we the contacts are
on the way
yeah so guys when it comes to
Valentine's Day
it's all about that candy
that's why I'm loving native's new
Limited Edition Candy Shop collection
like all Native products are
thoughtfully formulated to keep me
feeling and smelling delicious
you're gonna eat out of my armpitor
yeah so it's all aluminum free
uh the ingredients are all so simple
coconut oil shea butter baking soda
deodorant checks all the boxes 17 72
hours of odor protection
all the ingredients are natural
naturally derived
and it's a smooth residue free
application native also offers a variety
of scents with new and limited edition
scents being released all the time
that's fun I like that
I like you can experiment with all kinds
of different flavors
and when you use native you'll smell
amazing all day long thanks to their
long lasting scents do you want to smell
spicy
probably not well I guess they mean
probably like cinnamon not like like
like jalapeno you'll feel like you've
been pepper spray but I walk by you yeah
yeah do you want to smell spicy
do you want to spell woodsy
sweet or clean or fresh well they've got
all those options for you over at native
yeah
um what flavors are scents more
all different flavors uh this one is
mint
oh that's nice and which one which flip
uh which scent are you rocking here uh
this is sea salt and Cedar are you sure
Peter cheater it's a nightmare that is
like a nice masculine and he's he's very
Burly he's very manly comes in here and
we're all like wow yeah you would manian
oh man you like wood you like are you
into Cedar I'm more of an oak man myself
anyway now it's the time to switch uh
from an anti-perspirant to Native and
when you visit their site you can
discover all the fresh scents you may
even try out one of their body washes
while you're at it
it's our favorite product everybody here
is addicted
support the show and try this great
product right now go to Native
is this the right native Deo yep
native
deo.com after dark or use the promo code
after dark at checkout to get a sweet 20
off your first order that's native
d-e-o
.com after dark or use promo code after
dark at checkout for 20 send off your
first order thank you to Native we love
you so much please baby yes
okay
what do you think about this blue-eyed
King
Perfect Just the Way You Are
that's from um
okay well that's a good segue I had to
do a blood test for I know and they miss
it or something I don't know what
happened here because I thought they I
thought they pulled from here
but there's like an injection I guess
they did it there
does that happen to you or your arm
bruises up never that's the blood of God
apparently of like the tiniest veins
yeah because they're always like oh you
have tiny veins tiny [__] veins mine
are huge
yeah thanks Dan you know what they say
about Tony veins yeah but uh apparently
it sucks because people who there's
people who are good and they'll get it
the first time right but there are some
people that are just not that good at it
and they'll miss it like three yeah that
happens to you so many times I hate it I
just scared I get scared yeah because
when they get it right it's not bad it's
fine but when they keep stabbing me it
gets a little bit [__] Mr Mark with
that one
what does small veins mean does that
mean something about my health
I don't think so
because if you've got bigger veins you
got more space moldic energy
you know what I mean
I guess that's an interesting question
yeah I never thought it was like you
have like a heart attacks and stuff when
you get plaques in your veins
I think yours are just more visible
though no like mine are not visible at
all yeah it's like super deep maybe have
thick skin I'm not a doctor
is it that I have thick skin Maybe
I do have thin skin I've Been Told
okay well hey don't you know what I mean
because thicken up your skin you know
taking things too personal right aging a
decrease in muscle tone and weight gain
are common reasons for veins appearing
smaller
no they don't appear smaller a b they
are smaller
okay they've always been small don't
[__] give me that
moldic energy it's always been small
do you understand
yeah so I did um I feel like it's just
genetics because it's like something
you've always been like that yeah and
I've always been this way I think it's
just genetic yeah
but it's like remarkably small because
they always mention it
so something going on
people who do this all day are like God
damn you got small veins
so anyway I did a blood test to test for
STDs
and which you know
that should be just part of the process
yeah apparently they got they have to
screen you for STDs before they do the
IVF
and then they also did some kind of
genetic testing I don't know what for
but uh
um I don't know I just kind of said yes
to all the tests yeah yeah I'm in favor
of it
but so what happened was also I went and
nutted in a [__] cup
[Music]
and I have footage because it's kind of
a traumatic thing to go through
I hate this room so much
and I've been there before man
yeah here I was thinking about posting
this to insta stories I mean like guess
where I am right now because the last
time I took like a video
who's sitting in that
who the [__] in the right mind is
sitting in that
it's starting so so you walk in it's
like literally a Janitor's Closet
there's this chair here and right here
is a TV with one uh icon on the desktop
that just says it just takes you to porn
I guess oh God I didn't touch anything
obviously I hate being in there
it's so gross and so humiliating
and you gotta jerk off in a cup it's
just it's all wrong yeah wait that Matt
it's for you to sit on yeah it looks
like wet like it looks it wasn't wet I
don't know why it looks like that it
looks like a puppy [__] pad yeah it is
it is wait that's not like after like I
I mean I understand like if you're
sitting on I did not sit on it really I
think I'm crazy I didn't see them
oh my God I did not put a new one on
look when I was in there
it didn't look used but now look at it
[Laughter]
some persons just asked what
other accidents
so
um I didn't touch anything but last time
though I took a video and pictures right
there was like
that was a difficult
things on the wall you remember that
there was like a ton of paper towels in
the trash can like jizz covered paper
towels and a ton of Runnings water
liquid stains on the wall
file
so do they provide lubrication in there
they do but I'm not [__] psycho I'm
not touching any of that
there's a bottle of lube yeah there's
headphones can you imagine you're gonna
sit in that chair and use their
headphones
it's so wild
and so
yeah and then the thing is once you
capture it you have to write the exact
time on the bottle which is
also kind of gross
time stamp
you do they need the attack side and
then you put it in a Hazmat bag and you
put it in a paper bag and then I went to
the tech and he take he goes I'm gonna
make sure that it's all right he put on
gloves but he takes it out
the clear jar of semen let's stick his
finger in it taste a little pinky dip no
he didn't do it but he's like let me
just make sure all the info is right
it's so humiliating it's so gross like I
don't want to see him handling it I like
I don't want him looking at it in front
of me does he look at her like a nice
load man like does he well done yeah
well done well done
can you imagine
what if he was like dude yo dude
[__] man that would be the worst thing
that ever happened to me did he give it
a taste test like a Jay Shetty smoothie
yeah
no he just looked at it he didn't stick
his finger go you know like that's 20.
he didn't do that all right can you guys
stop please I'm being serious right now
this was hard it's a tough situation oh
my God
[Laughter]
oh this is Aiden Ross this so
that's how you prove it
he totally would be doing it [__]
weirdo
oh my God that is very funny
what do you smell down there Aiden a
little [__] jizz
yeah so the last time I just handed them
the paper bag and I left which was good
I like that I don't want to see anybody
looking at it but this guy insisted hand
me the bag I'm taking the jar of jizz
out I'm holding it to the light
and I'm gonna read like a dollar what
making sure it's real make sure it's not
fake it's the real deal dog
and so anyway yeah I hate doing that
[__] man I when I walked in there was
like hello darkness my old friend
so I've come to jizz again
but anyway my gist checked out right
healthy load
I don't know much yet
they're like sir
um we have a problem your jizz is 50 uh
hamburger ground hamburger meat coming
you eat a lot of hamburgers sir
oh we have a problem half of your jizz
is like pizza of Grease
oh [__]
I'm gonna come oh my Lord I thought he
was reading my fortune in the jizz
and so I guess everything mine mine is
good yeah you're all done so enough
complaining poor ELO has to go through
every gun that's all your
that's everything you got to do here
well no I have that music again in the
cup yeah one more time to go and jizz
again and you believe what they put me
through enough
like you didn't have no this was just
for the analysis
the IVF is gonna happen
dude what do you do with it
so on Monday it is I need to start all
the shots and that's gonna be insane did
you get just you know what I'm so sorry
did you get your shots to do this
because I know it's like
I just did talked about my [__] and now
we don't talk about your ship I have to
pee I need to pee too actually okay
great let's do it and then we'll come
back and talk about it
so let's do that and we'll be right back
how bad you have to pee right now
you know when Ethan was telling that
story reminded me of one time me and
Lena went to the doctor and it was just
some doctor near our College in Detroit
we'd never been there and there was just
piss cups all over the counter like some
of them were stacked on top of each
other it was just the worst doctor's
office I've ever been in it was an open
bar remember that Lena yeah didn't he
get indicted that doctor what is it Lena
didn't that doctor get indicted hey he
did get indicted but we don't need to
talk about it
yeah but yeah it was really gross I
have cups everywhere and it will oh
there's a doctor's office not like well
he got indicted so I don't know maybe he
wasn't a doctor I don't know it sounds
very safe okay I'll give you guys some
more context you used to come to our
restaurant
and this guy the doctor hope he washed
his hands and he used to give the cook
free prescriptions in exchange for free
food I was like hey
all right
[Music]
all different flavors and now he's a
food delivery guy it's really sad Lena
you why'd you just say his name
why don't you just say this name is this
point oh
Dr schmeckle with the piss cups
food delivery again he wasn't asking he
was an [__] though he was really mean
to the other stuff so I guess karma got
him man Karma [__] his ass man you know
more at the end of the story it ended up
being a Jimmy Lee everyone he got back
in practice he's a dentist he actually
yeah he changed his name and moved to
Jersey and just
I have a little story who's here um over
winter break I went to New York and my
friend had a very cute little dog and my
parents have dogs and I'd stop by and I
see them all the time I'm literally not
scared of them but for some reason at
one point like an hour into the night I
had pet the dog everything was good but
it made a little noise that I guess just
like freaked me out so much that I burst
into tears and then just started
laughing so loud because I was like what
am I what am I doing and I was with
people I just met for the first time and
then I had to explain to everybody like
I'm not actually scared of this dog I'm
not actually sad right now I just I had
an incident and then that was that was
like a flashback to the to the Pitbull I
didn't even get that like my body just
started crying and then I was like what
the heck don't look at me right now you
guys oh my God the other day I was
recording a video and a spider just
crawled onto my phone and I couldn't
grab my phone because and ab wasn't home
and I was freaking out it was like
literally the scariest thing ever is it
recorded yeah oh my God I need to I
posted as a tick tock it was just it was
so scary
and that then scene
I hate spiders
oh we sat down the exact same time I saw
that yeah that was nice because you're
insane
again so we're trying to have a third
baby I don't know if I said that oh
[Applause]
I thought we were just talking about you
jerking at the doctor this wasn't a a
Sunday afternoon uh yeah that doctor's
that doctor's office he was actually
there for uh for a nose and throat
to do with fertility
a little cough you know you know can you
jerk off in this cup please he's like
sir your mucus is a little runny
this mucus
weird color
so oh yeah so I did my part obviously I
can't complain this whole thing for me
was like
Ela if you want a third baby it's up to
you because this is all all you got to
go through all the hardest [__] I just
don't I'm in you too right like we're
both kind of going back and forth on the
idea a lot but we're like when it's hard
currently then we're like uh we don't
need any more right after Bruce was born
we're like [__] having a third baby yeah
but
we're always kind of wandering and then
I I've been talking to
like people about us wondering and then
um somebody well my trainer actually was
like if there's a doubt then you guys
should probably do it because usually
when people are done they're like hell
no they're like not even thinking about
it done done you know I kind of thought
that made a lot of sense I thought that
was really good advice too because
usually you hear the Opposites like if
you're in doubt don't do it yeah but
hers was really good because when you're
talking about having a kid
you don't them you lose out with more
time the longer you wait the more you're
losing out because we want our kids to
be in the same age you're going to be
older which means you're going to have
less [__] time with them as your ass
gets older and it's very physical like
keeping up with them is hard physically
so I thought that was really good advice
that that's what convinced me too
um and I do really hope to have a girl
because I just feel like it would be a
completely different experience than you
know Mom and a boy versus Mom and a girl
for me
um so yeah I think the and I'm I don't
know I feel like all the training that I
do kind of
my body feels like
in a better spot than ever so I kind of
feel like I'm not too worried about
another pregnancy right now
that's like I can do it that's awesome
so that's good you know um
we're trying to find a a hospital closer
because you guys know last time this
baby just fell out I wasn't even there
for the birth so ela's like we gotta
find a hospital that's close yeah
because last time we got so lucky it was
the middle of the night and so there was
no traffic but even without traffic it's
like 25 minutes
and if it ends up doing traffic like I'm
just not taking that chance there's no
way not doing that again so
I think you're going to give birth in
the car if anything you know it's like
[__] yeah so people are asking how does
it work with IV IVF can you choose the
gender so what's gonna happen now is
after I take all the hormones and all
the stuff they're going to be giving me
um they're gonna
take out the eggs under when they're
gonna put me under and like take the
eggs out so it depends on how many
I'll have and how many of them you had
20. you're like stacked that's just
follicles but that the phone call is
where the egg will grow or something
like that super hard for me to follow
okay but um yes there's a good chance
that we'll have like a few good ones
because from that amount that you start
with not all of them are going to be
good ones it could be like you start
with six but only one will be good
you're like this kid will suck you don't
want him I don't know what it means but
that's what it's gonna be dumb for sure
you don't want that egg no I think it's
the viability I think like a higher
quality egg is less likely two years old
and a miscarriage miscarriage yeah yeah
yeah so once we see I don't know if
we'll have a few options then I think it
means we can choose because if you if
they can say you have a good option here
for a boy or a good option for a girl we
know we only want one so we can pick
which one yeah because sometimes like
there's there's a chance that you put
them back in and the pregnancy won't go
through still so sometimes people will
put two even and they're like well if it
does we'll take the risk of having twins
would you do that I would not do that no
not willing to this I was kind of open
to the idea of having twins I was like
[__] it let's just do this for family
crazy and I was like there's no way in
hell that I'm doing that because I'm
okay with carrying one baby I don't want
to do that to my body carry two babies
yeah I can see that really [__] up
your back and it's like a high risk
pregnancy
and I I was like all the way through the
end I was working I was doing stuff like
when it's high risk pregnancy you're
just like laying down the whole end of
the pregnancy because it's just insane
okay
yeah so the IVF is it's actually really
tough like so tell about the process now
because you're doing all these shots and
stuff
um so yeah on Monday I'm starting the
shots and it's gonna be for 8 to 12 Days
depending on how it develops but it's
two shots in the evening
and then at some point uh in the middle
of those eight days there will be also a
third shot in the morning
and it's just like I don't know I I the
one that is painful is the one that I
already had to do last time
I'm not looking forward to that one the
thing it burns when it goes in sucks
dude I have to do it and it like really
hurts Hilo it's like yeah
I don't like that one but uh we already
did that so I'm kind of like well I'm
I've been there I've done it
and then so we so we do all that and
then they give you like a trigger shot
or something like that when they're
ready when they're like okay it's ready
they get there's a trigger thing and
then basically we're gonna go for the
egg retrieval so when is that happening
so that might happen around like March
1st they said depending on depending on
how everything goes but and then when do
we do the IVF
so I take it step by step because it's a
lot of information every time so right
now this is all I'm like it's probably
soon after that it will be soon enough
they got the sperms down like beginning
of the process like very very beginning
to the very end of like you're pregnant
is about three months oh but at the very
beginning already because I had to be
for two weeks on birth control pills
which I've already done yeah
um so that's the very beginning okay so
then so there's still a while so there's
still a while because once they've
started they retrieved eggs then I don't
know what they do to it and um yeah
yeah and so um
yeah it was a tough decision to come to
but we we ultimately decided I think
you're gonna get your your little girly
too
it's crazy that you want to name her
like um
big fart energy I thought that was a
perfect for a girl you sound like
Theodore now
the name is still Olive right
oh so we're saying it yeah why not we
already did
yeah we never did
oh yeah she did no we didn't you guys
did yeah we did uh back
with Bruce when Bruce was coming you you
were disgusting okay boy and girl name
options
I always loved that name
I love olives me too maybe that has
something to do with it but I had a
friend you want to honor your employee
here too oh yeah well that's a different
she has a different name it's a
different name completely different dad
is it 100 different
when you're talking about you know the
genome
it's everything we've always like from
the very beginning when we decided to
have kids we had the name Theodore for
Roy and only for girl it was always that
in college I had a friend
and she told me that she had a baby
sister and her name was Olive and I I
always thought that was so cute
I had never met a girl named Olive I
guess maybe it's an old-timey name
but I thought that was so cute and I
always remembered that that would be a
nice name
a little Olive
kit Olive is the name of the lead in
spelling bee which I think she's such a
cute character oh really yeah so that's
what I think about
Olivia so I won't be able to sing that
to her but oh Liv oh
ultimately I just want I just no and
Oliver tree
totally different name so don't even
bring his [__] name into this
hate him
and so then when you're doing all these
shots and stuff
they they instructed me that I have to
I have to I have ejaculate ejaculate see
that's more gross ejaculate to me is a
grosser word then it is
doesn't sound what's grocery ejaculate
or jizz
come just I think I mean ejaculate is
like the scientific term so yeah but
it's nasty
I think I think it's situated like the
doctoral way of saying it because it
ejaculates like you can see it like it's
like a jacket because you can ejaculate
other things than semen I just see it
like big squirts you can
[Music]
you can ejaculate things other than
semen it's like a descriptive words
adjective or no it was a verb I think
yeah
yeah it's a verb Dan
verb form to cornhole so you need to
ejaculate every three days yeah that's
gonna be tough
Eva's gonna have to take these super
painful shots in the gut and I'm gonna
have to jerk off every three days
skeet
that's not that gross somehow I mean
it's not it's under people's radar for a
long time that's how they played on the
radio for so long I need to Skeet every
three days it'll get gross tons of dirty
yes it'll get girls fast some people are
saying big squirts
you know let's do a poll I see lots of
conflicted opinions on this
what's a grocer term
ejaculate
uh it's gross or jizz or jizz
well see I guess if it's one or the
other you can't really
you can't really add more options eh
so
this could be useful information people
at home okay
so here's how you should refer to this
from now on
to the doctor I love that going to the
doctor be like so I got a gist in a cup
what about like relieve myself
that's that's peeing yeah is it yeah how
much it's like it sounds kind of like
it's like how bad do you need relief bro
I never knew that I thought you were
like relieving yourself of the Demons
seriously yeah people go I need to go
relieve myself they go in the back yeah
yeah that means you thought they're
going to jerk off that like Cheesecake
Factory yeah
jizz is actually winning 55 percent
[Music]
oh yeah
love you I notice he doesn't go up to
the next register because he's he's
smart he knows he knows his limits he's
no witness but that's okay
I'm here
[Music]
Austin Butler twins
I know
he will always love you
he does have a beautiful voice it's he's
lovely he is lovely you know what was um
a crazy moment when we decided like okay
let's talk to the doctor yeah and tell
her you know that we're interested in
doing this yeah so I went to my text
messages
with her
and
when I opened it
the first thing that came up was wait
where is it I like that you could text
with this doctor that's pretty badass
the first thing that came up was when
she texted me when we were live oh yeah
392 you're super pregnant yeah
and I was like oh my God but I forgot
that's how it happened that's awesome
that's us
oh
you really let me out left me out to
drive
all right thank you Logan he said peace
and love I just got a lavender snowball
hoodie all right man keep just keep that
to yourself brother
I'm warning you peace and love do not
wear that outside your hard work chips
and drip thank you for the Ted
appreciate you actually I have a few
people to thank here
sorry if I missed you questri m says I'm
currently pregnant with a baby girl
through IVF and she only had six
follicles congratulations I feel like
there's a good chance we'll get that
little olives
or we're just gonna be a [__] zoo
with three boys
that'll be a goddamn two male dogs it's
just crazy I'm like I'm all bruised up
all the time it's like the boy energy is
a lot dudes Rock dude a lot dudes
[__] rock man the energy that
Theodore is
presenting is it's like crazier it's
like 9 p.m he should have been in bed
already and he's like running circles
around the kitchen and he has he has so
much energy he doesn't know how to
express it he'll run around and he goes
like he's just bugging out because he's
so he's just buzzing with energy
he just goes
he's feeling his body and stuff
and then so now Bruce is getting old
enough where they're starting to wrestle
and [__] and Bruce is gonna be a whole
trouble too man
yeah so we need some we need some girl
power
and I'm thinking like when I was a kid I
would go shopping with my mom it was
such a fun bonding experience and just
like
I could use somebody to go shopping when
[Music]
mm-hmm I mean maybe the boys will be
into my clothes I I always tell Diego
because he he likes playing in my closet
and I'm like Monday when it can fit you
maybe you can wear my shoes and stuff
uh yeah so thank you thank you everybody
so yeah that's what's going on so that's
kind of going to be our lives for the
next three months yeah and then that's
gonna be our lives for the next
30 25 or hopefully 18 years that kid's
getting out of the house at 18.
18 and you're gone you hear me Olive
and a [__] job you're already pissing
me off oh no somebody said oh my God
shopping with my mom was traumatizing
for me it was very traumatizing I hated
it
I love that but see I didn't like I
didn't care about clothes at all exactly
I just wanted to get like a t-shirt and
shorts and leave as soon as possible and
that's where we're different yeah and
Theodore is like you like I'll I buy him
this cute shoes and he won't even try it
he's three he refuses to try it on
because he's three
I don't know if I put that on him yet
he's three and a half to be fair yeah
he makes a distinction I'm three and a
half a big deal big deal well at that
age that's you know sixth of your whole
life so it kind of is
so there's that we have officially
gotten through
three topics four topics of our show
these are the best episodes we have
about 500.
[Music]
you'll know
foreign
[Music]
so
is it stupid to even ask but is this AI
how'd you guys do this yeah there's it's
some kind of uh Advanced software that
can separate the vocals from the
background music and then you can ask
like sing their song and it doesn't no
that's him we took a real song
of him singing over music
and we I this is a real person you know
that right
no but
it's hard to believe it's a real person
well no he he is using uh an app that
kind of like auto-tunes him a little bit
right but he actually was singing these
songs
able to isolate isolate just him yeah
with the software okay because he does
like karaoke style yeah yeah like did
you isolate chestnuts I did yeah let me
hear that I'm curious how that one came
out
[Music]
so good
he's really got this down
[Music]
foreign
yeah we're reached out to him I don't
know if I mentioned that I want to get
this man on phone immediately
um
um somebody said Ella my mom was a
graphic designer and she would pull up a
chair and have me help design logos and
Brands and would even make shirts have
fun and like I love that I did that a
couple times with Theodore and he's
great like I showed him a few color
options and I was like which ones are
your favorites or I showed him like I
had to remember one time I had to pick
yarn colors and I let him pick colors
and he actually has like good taste yeah
you picked good options yeah he's super
in arts and crafts and stuff he's very
like creative and colorful and like so
yeah
um what were you gonna save me we're
about to oh I found out today that uh
that gentleman actually does a bunch of
duets with this uh girl who maybe even
better than him they're really good
together
duet of uh chestnuts actually together
can I just sample it yeah I actually I
removed the background Audio Oh already
[__] yeah dude that's what I want right
now I'm exporting it right now so just
give me
move it
anyway moving on thank you well can't
wait for that uh Mr Beast Deez Nuts
commercial
kind of a good commercial honestly
or maybe what do you guys think is it
funny or is it stupid I guess I don't
know
it's all dumb
what's the biggest thing you've ever
made the biggest thing I've ever made
probably these nuts when Jimmy told me
about Deez Nuts I knew it was going to
be huge when Jimmy first told me about
Deez Nuts I thought he was crazy I love
Deez Nuts same I keep it pair on me at
all times these nuts taste so good it's
like this amazing peanut butter
chocolate flavor nut tap
that's good nuts you have to try these I
love how Mr Beast is like he he's acting
like he invented chocolate
he's like it's in this incredible peanut
butter chocolate flavor
it's like a two dollar chocolate bar we
know
have you guys ever tried this it's it's
this thing called chocolate
so I you're these nuts connoisseur love
what did you think about it
uh I mean I think it's obviously
slightly self-aware yeah yeah so that I
mean that is kind of good because if
they were doing this without being aware
I mean yeah that would be bad but I
think it it's a little bit cringy still
honestly a little crazy and as you said
it's like bro you're just it's just
chocolate with nothing it's a two dollar
chocolate bar with nuts in it like at
the end of the day you got to try a
little bit harder Mr Beast come on now
well he doesn't actually that's the part
that's the part is
um is the one dude is he actually
driving that car probably they're all
super rich now
he gives one of these out every video
it's kind of wild
but um
you know not bad he said he was going to
buy a Super Bowl ad but apparently even
that was too expensive for Jimmy seven
million dollars would have cost
it's crazy how is that worth it I don't
know
seven million dollars and I can't even
find a sponsor
bro Mr this is kind of poor dude
he is poor yeah he can't afford that
yeah so there's that Deez Nuts given a
lukewarm approval from Love
yeah speaking of buying ads did you see
what I uh sent you this morning that the
post yes can you pull it up
yeah we were talking about buying a um
billboard
okay because Tim Poole put up this
really embarrassing billboard in Times
Square
super cringy super pointless super dumb
and so we wanted to oh yeah have a
dueling billboard and we actually got
some quotes on some real premium real
estate one of them is actually right
above Pink's Hot Dogs literally like one
hanging over which
I got to tell you for the sake of Jimmy
I think we kind of have to should we do
something about like Jimmy Lee's books
here's what here's what we were talking
about hold on I think it would be so
funny if we told him we are getting him
a billboard above pinks and he's so
excited he's so excited about it and
then in the corner of the billboard is
where Jimmy's Place but a tiny Jimmy and
it's just you it's a billboard of you
that's the Jimmy is featured by the way
this Tim Poole paid somebody in Times
Square New York yeah to put this [__] up
like dude what
foreign
seriously
well so we're wondering how much this
cost I don't know yeah Times Square But
the spot above pinks is premium real
estate and it was ten thousand dollars
for two months what was it or not that
long how long what was the time period
we got it was like two weeks really okay
yeah because I was gonna so that doesn't
sound that expensive so 10K for two
weeks
here's the the potential location right
here that's
where is it
it's on Melrose Hollywood
because this looks like an old building
right here looks like L.A there's always
foot traffic outside of Pinks too that's
like okay okay yeah it's like slammed
over there so do you think we could buy
one that says pinks hot dogs suck or
something
I don't know if they'd let you like they
probably veto that go to Ethan's hot
dogs way better than pinks
so we've been trying to think if we have
a good idea I guess it's is it I guess
it's worth ten thousand I mean I've sold
I've spent money on Dumber
Dumber things for sure
but we need what would you do yeah and
so there's the Tim pool thing there's
the Jimmy Lee thing
um
maybe it could just be like
it could be or we could actually try to
promote the podcast we could see like
what's this the craziest idea we can put
up there to try to actually promote the
podcast but I would want to do it for
already spending the money because the
concept isn't for people on the street
to go see the poster and then go to your
show the objective is for people on the
street to take a picture because it's so
absurd and posted to social media
yeah viral what damn we should just post
one of Jimmy's deep fried memes like one
of those [__] insane ones yeah that
wouldn't help benefit me much but it
would be funny I think you'd give them a
heart attack but I mean an ad for the
podcast but in that style of just like
deep fried to [__] we shouldn't do one
of those hypothetical ones he was
freaking out about like him at like uh
Auschwitz being like work with me
he's standing over like a mass grave
tough audience
laughs
yeah so Lee Harvey Oswald was a jersey
Outlaw fan it's him holding a rifle or
something
so I don't know
maybe we could have an idea
audience
and the winner gets to uh
bragging rights they I'll pay him
something
or they can put something stinker a
little something in the poster
you know
so if you guys have any ideas let me
know do a giant QR code ah oh that's
Foodies that's your homie Love yup shout
out okay I see I see you giant QR code
what's the QR code then just the
lemonparty.com or something
I just want to fake a Jimmy Lee tweet
just with him saying something like
uh Pink's Hot Dog sucks so I'm gonna
spend ten thousand dollars to yeah
the already most embarrassing man alive
but the goal has to be just sour Pink's
Hot Dogs relationship with the Jimmy Lee
I think that's so funny so they put it
pinks put up a picture of Jimmy Lee
so if we could do something to make it
seem like there's been some some
friction and then go in there and be
like hey you know that guy in your wall
is talking [__] right he uh he keeps
continuing to uh to call me about this
restaurant idea he has uh he's like it's
the biggest restaurant in La and the
shoot would be huge if we did it I'm
like well you know it's just a
restaurant you mean I'm like what's your
idea he's like we go and [__] with
people and like I'm like Jimmy like it's
the same [__] like he's like but you
know my guys will be there you guys will
be there and he's just out of his
[__] mind
he's he can't change he can't no of he
won't I've got this great idea I'm gonna
go in the kitchen and ask the chefs hey
show me your papers work with me he he
also he put me on the phone with like a
restaurant manager he's like hey this is
that exact talk to I forgot the dude's
name he's like talk to him I'm like who
the [__] am I talking to right now like
like I mean he's like this guy's the
biggest manager of restaurants I put you
on the phone with the manager also you
have no Authority you're not you know
what I mean like who's what somebody
that's kind of funny yeah this is pretty
I if there was like a live picker but
it's going down right oh my god
oh somebody said you and Hassan kissing
it's kind of funny
I say like QR code to the prolapse or to
uh I don't know Ryan or Harvey
I'm sure they're pretty funny for the
right right the prolapse a terrible idea
yeah I'm sure they're gonna check what
it is I think I'll get arrested okay
well what's interesting with a QR code
is that you can change it when it's up
oh you can do a fast one on them yeah
Dan B donated shekels what's up said can
you open it up to suggestions from the
subreddit sure
yeah I'd love that
any ideas or good ideas
so
people are saying that me kissing is
queer baiting shame on you guys oh okay
there you guys just wait you come you
can't kiss a homie come on Mom I guess
if you're using it in the ad I can see
that it's like
that's a big game man
yeah uh so give me your ideas I'm
definitely open to wasting 10K on this
why not you know why not
so that's pretty exciting hey you guys
want to be super depressed
no on this lovely Friday afternoon no
we're having a good time what do you
mean it's not that depressing it's just
a little concerning it's a little
concerning work with me
we talked about Ohio the toxic yeah
[__] disaster of the train derailing
Vinyl chloride everybody's favorite yeah
toxin to breed
by the way I'm still waiting for that
daily report on it I know I watched your
episode it's annoying me yeah so here
the people there um in East Palestine
are I'm doing them so generous by saying
Palestine is that the correct way
correct way to practice okay it smells
exactly the same but the town's people
there were saying it that way I heard
the towns person say Palestine okay so
I'm trying to honor him and he's like
I'll live in Palestine yeah it's
goddammit
we're way richer and better off than
them in like debilitating shacks and
[__] basically they live in a war
zone
uh so here's their Creeks over there in
Palestine check this out
when you throw a rock wow it looks
normal and then when you throw a rock
it's all in the bottom of the creek bed
no
it could be like soap that they're using
to try and clean the [__] up too that's
all somebody suggest
um but yeah I mean that's their what
drink I mean still not good right yeah I
don't want that I just want your water
to be iridescent generally
so and the EPA was like no it's all good
right
the EPA has been saying the air is
totally fine and the drinking water is
all good thank you so when they say that
the head of the EPA needs to come down
and drink out of this Creek
and he needs to go to that crash site
and breathe deep and then come tell me
how good it is yeah
this is what Jay Shetty shakes are
actually made out of
here yeah
that's pretty disturbing right yeah yeah
it's actually getting around 12 million
views on that which is nice but I still
wish
I know it's become a meme like
everyone's like oh they're not covering
it I mean they are covering it they're
starting to but I I just like yeah why
isn't it a bigger story
I do still feel like it's not hitting
the mainstream like the television the
podcasts where I want to be hearing
about it
it they're not treating it like it's a
big story
you know the New York Times did again I
listened to daily every day they did
another story today about [__] Bing
to being storied back to back and I
can't hear about oh this
it's like the scrape in the bottom of
the barrel yo what the [__]
JD Vance the phony ass [__] you
Senator hillbilly such a phony
hey guys so I'm here at Leslie run and
there's dead worms and Dead Fish all
throughout this water so something I
just discovered is that if you scrape
the creek bed it's like chemical is
coming out of the ground can you show
can you come here and let me just show
this to people well I don't know if
you're going to see this on the camera
but watch this
that chemical pop out of the creek this
is disgusting and the fact that we have
not cleaned up the the train crash the
fact that these chemicals are still
seeping in the ground well dude it's
been it's like just happened
it's good that he's there bringing
attention to it he's the center of Ohio
I mean these are the people that are
supposed to be representing them and
he's there talking about it so yeah
that's good I don't I don't like him but
I can appreciate him I saw people
complaining that
um
it took him like 10 days to respond or
something but whatever
this video is crazy too this is actually
a privately owned Railway it's got
nothing to do just to be clear with what
the accident that happened but this is
still really [__] crazy what I don't
know they're privately owned like there
needs to be some red I think from what I
was reading is just some short tract for
yeah on private property or something
but you cannot it's like not use
somebody needs to regulate this
watch this [__] this is so sketchy it's
so [__] up
look at this oh my God this is in
America
the richest nation that's ever existed
my son's train attacks are better
constructed than this like if I knew
that I
win but do you think
be free oh
I mean what in the gods [__] green
goddamn Earth of this [__] boy that
train tracks all over the damn place
yeah don't worry they're just they're
just shipping uh enriched uranium
nothing hazardous
wow this is how we transport our
vinyl chloride in the safest way
possible
we just fired all of our workers
that's so crazy
yeah again though that isn't like a
major line or anything it's just it's
just kind of interesting you know by the
way these are all posts from like right
wing provocative debunked I don't know
somebody in the chat this was yeah well
they are starting they were slow on the
uh uptick but they are starting to
realize that uh
that this is something to hammer Biden
over so they're not wrong but I just
think it's funny it's like are you
complaining about infrastructure because
we're on the same page let's go
but she you know I mean let's let's do
that yeah I mean they're just
opportunistic I don't think they
actually care yeah especially since
their boy Trump is the one who killed
all the breaking law or regulations and
stuff so
whoops yeah so that is pretty wild
um there was some other news out of
there
oh like there's this conspiracy going
around because now that this happened
yeah people are noticing like oh there's
a train crash here do you have that
write-up of that Dan
um
I guess not so there's a lot of train
crashes people are noticing now
okay yeah oh the one in Detroit and some
of them and a lot of them are having
like hazardous material and there's
fires
and everyone's wondering like what the
[__] is going on with all these trains
crashing now there's conspiracy theories
about like uh we're under attack or the
government as crashing trains or some
[__] I don't know the threat that we saw
was somebody who thinks the government
is intentionally doing it which is just
like
so not sure the [__] brain broken
right there
not sure on the uh
the motive there
uh but great what was that this was in
Detroit there was another one of Florida
that I caught fire it looked super crazy
what's going on and my question was is
this
um
I found out there's actually 1700 train
crashes a year oh
trains are just crashing and I don't
think anybody really noticed or cared
until this happened and now the sudden
people were like oh there's train
crashes there's chemicals yeah and I
think I don't think there's anything
going on I think it's just this is just
par for the course trains just be
crashing right which it should be said
they are still way safer than um
Trucking like as a method of
transporting Freight like the amount of
accidents on the highways right there's
like 10 times that of trains so right
um another so yeah then this is going on
in Florida people this is what's
happening another coincidence this time
in Florida are these intentional acts of
sabotage literally just a normal ass
fire like it has nothing to do with the
train there's no train it's just like oh
yeah a building lit on fire that that
does happen but I saw even Philly D
taking the bait on this kind of
conspiratorial thinking
let's see he put a tweet out like Oh The
Coincidence are getting out of control
another train derailment
with the uh hmm what does it mean
I wanna I have a conspiracy why haven't
I been in any thumbnails recently Phil
oh
okay why is Belle Delphine in your
[__] thumbnails she's literally not
even in the news that's a question I
have for Ability right she just put out
a song with the dad in the video
um yeah we'll see you with that why
should you trade her I thought she was
our homie well everyone she's getting a
little bit of [__] for betraying the
family but I have a theory I have a
theory that
Bell is distracting his ass because she
he had to fly out overseas and that took
up some time he could be training so I'm
glad she's still actually loyal she's
deep undercover okay
how'd she even find that doesn't have
like 10 views per video
she even knows who he is
um
[Music]
I got a conspiracy theory Phil
it's
uh I'm looking for something where Jay
Shetty or no this is Darman
he's a darn man
waiting in Burbank I got a conspiracy
theory it's been two weeks since I've
been in a thumbnail [__]
oh why were you in the thumbnail I don't
want to talk about it
maybe that's a good thing Ethan yeah I
guess so well I don't know why his song
gets so many thumbnails he doesn't get
in controversies as much where is he
here's one
Andrew Tate Hogwarts Legacy like what's
that have to do with the sun why is he
in it
he was probably in it because of the
fundraiser
pull out
um okay Hassan hasn't been here's
another one it's on banned for spreading
hate
what are you talking about that didn't
even happen is that it yeah that's one
of his tick tock tick tock it might take
still got banned where's my [__]
thumbnail
you're right it's not about something
horrible I did you're right you're right
can I be the victim in one of your
stories Phil
like Hassan gets
play it
LEDs Knox ability is nuts
for sure
got him
yeah go ahead play this song
[Music]
there's a duet coming oh I just sent it
in the main chat oh it's a video oh no
way we got a video with just vocals
that's so fire wow so here's technology
this is what technology is doing okay so
they kind of edited together yeah they
have a lot of videos like this together
like over 20.
um all right cheers
[Music]
to make decisions
beautiful voice as well
[Music]
wait what was that what was their their
dare was that a lyric that I
tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
and every mother's child
[Music]
to fly
oh I can listen to that all day that was
that was beautiful dude wow
[__] yeah so
actually we do have a segment today
other than talking about the baby
actually maybe we should add we're
having a third baby and green screen
challenge we're having a tournament
a green screen tournament
the winner this is just for funsies like
the um the Kafka diss track one so we'll
do like the same kind of prize uh
prize breakdown what was it it was 500
to the winner
300 to second place
and a hundred to three and four right oh
my God I want a car
maybe three should be 101 you know it's
a little bit a little more money
so
500 300 100 100 okay
so there it is so I'm going to step over
to the green screen here and I'm going
to act out a whole bunch of stuff
and whoever delivers
the most incredible green screen to
Ethan will will rank them like we did
with the freestyles and there's so many
talented
so do they have to use all of them or
just no no okay so just combine whatever
they want yep and are we taking
suggestions from the audiences sure yeah
I mean I'm just gonna go out there and
act out whatever you guys want let's go
I've got props I've got a whole bunch of
stuff to look through I'm gonna I just I
need to pee again this G fuels [__]
no gamer sup bro
exactly gamer sub gamer sub Gamers up
Gamers up Gamers up we've only
what's up
spinal cord deep without Vinyl chloride
in it gamer sup is filtered through
charcoal 20 times
[Music]
HD podcast slash
gamersoft.com
[Music]
the two of us
it's beautiful
real quick as a quick housekeeping thing
anybody entering the green screen
contest make sure you don't use any uh
copyrighted music or you'll be tossed in
the bin with peace and love all right
thank you thank you thank you Wham
you guys go wild with it
so I'm seeing ELO that uh that name
brand God or gcds I guess maybe they
changed their name Giuliano culza Design
Studio probably wheelchairing that but
j-r-h-n-br really I have no idea
yep
anyone here from Arizona Arizona
are you gonna do some some green screen
uh stuff Ila I'll fill it out I'm gonna
see what Ethan does okay you guys should
perform a scene yeah
[Music]
anyone got uh fun plans for the weekend
oh I'm going to a rave tomorrow night oh
you guys are more than welcome to join
if you'd like but
I'm gonna dance the night away
yeah I love dancing dude dude you would
have loved you would love the Rave love
yeah
I'm going to get beat up today
nice the first day he's putting me in
with the uh the more experienced boxers
for sparring and I've been super nervous
all morning but I can't wait to get it
over with
[Music]
um
Eli with Teddy fresh ever consider
making some cool neckties I can wear at
work we do have something coming out
soon
and I think you could wear it to work
so
[Music]
let's see if you like it
what else let's see my neck doesn't
exist
[Music]
so I need to put on my non-green screen
shirt which I'll do for you guys
okay
maybe go no shirt for a couple
oh [__] that all right
hell yeah
do I have all right this is just this is
just a couple of the like the Ethan what
are you doing you can't do a green
screen contest with her shirt off dude
I'm Justin oh Cam stop it I'm just in
the podcast I lost a couple weights and
I love having my shirt off Who's Gonna
Stop Me
wow I'm a lot hairier than him
hey guys or someone yeah cue me up again
Ethan what are you doing you know you
can't do a green screen contest with
your shirt off dude I just love doing
the green screen contest with my shirt
off I've lost a few wakes and I'm
feeling really good about myself I don't
know I just like it
maybe some Alpha stuff
I'm maybe surfing
and I'm getting cut off it's got to be
all along
oh we're gonna people are gonna have fun
with that people are saying do the arm
thing okay good idea do the arm thing
can you look at the camera and do it yep
there we go
[Laughter]
[__] up
all right can I put my shirt back on
please no yeah no no
okay ready did you get a couple like
hold on
hi there thanks for tuning in today
we're going to talk about reverse
mortgages and how they can benefit you
and your loved ones
any other pitches you should do that
again but don't talk about reverse
mortgages just make it seem more generic
than that and you're that you're
referencing whatever's behind you okay
hi there I'm Ethan Klein you know in
today's society people go through a lot
of hard times I mean take a look at
these guys here it's really been a tough
time but I'm here with the Miracle
Solution this is going to change how you
see everything join me on this journey
that's a good one okay let me put on a
shirt huh
they're all going to be shirtless
yeah that's true
you're some soy jacks
oh yeah I gave us some soy Jacks let me
just but I'm sure
okay
soy Jack like what just like
this point yeah
[Laughter]
[Applause]
yeah maybe some Shadow Boxing something
like Hydro kidneys
hey fit hey Philly watch out hide your
kidneys ah right there
keep your hands up where's that liver
boom
where's that spleen
boom can you turn sideways and then act
like you're punching an opponent yeah
are you on the hiking trail with Philly
yeah there you go there you go
[Laughter]
all right how about like a Mortal Kombat
character oh yeah yeah
[Music]
well mortal kombat's to the side a
little bit yeah yeah I like that yeah
there you go yeah
cast The Fireball
oh yeah we do do we need more likes
maybe I'll do I'll do like um really
clean motions it's like a kid on the
playground
can you step take a step back one step
backwards yeah there you go
I think you guys may want to do one
where you can see his legs still yeah I
think so too
yeah that's
that's gonna be a buzz kill can we pull
the camera back
right I could I can make the ground
green
we're gonna need the ground green
somebody grow some grass real quick
ground
I think we need some like just walking
with the whole body okay yeah yeah and
so maybe running away from something
yeah
[Music]
oh there there's some old green screen
stuff that you guys posted where you
have like a sword do you guys remember
that from me yeah it was the uh boot
staking boot
no not even before that I think
wait do we have a sword where you can
just like Swing Swing we do have the
belt Delphin sword yeah I can grab that
all right that'd be awesome we do have
that yeah can someone know where that is
got it
true Sports
scared in place running that's a good
idea
stand by enjoy the Sweet Serenade
better than nothing
I mean it's keying out from what I can
see
[Music]
um
as these work guys work on I guess we
could talk about something maybe you can
do some voice acting really well oh just
some uh
I don't know grunting I don't know why
you want me to start grunting Dozer I
don't know dude I'm thinking yeah
you want to talk about little Duvall
what is that dude you're gonna freak the
[__] out when you see this so I don't
know is this guy a rapper or comedian
what's the deal with little Duvall
he's not a rapper
Instagram comedian is he a successful
comedian
I guess I've not seen any of his
material
but there's some old really old tweets
that we service but they're really
[__] weird
you know what I mean
so y'all tell me what you think about
these
little Duval I guess he's got a rapper
name that's why everyone thinks he's a
rapper
his name is not Lil is it
that doesn't make a lot of sense to me
so you ready for this healer I guess
oh he was a 2005 finalist on BET's
comedy competition okay
I just want to say thank you to
Lee Feldman who wrote me in Hebrew
Elon
animals
she said she loves the sparkle in my
eyes oh what a sweetheart thank you all
right now this goes back to 2012 so
again this is 11 years ago
so I'm gonna I just want to disclose
that before I read these you know you
know it's yeah how old was he when he
posted this
so he says when my daughter's period
starts that's when I'm gonna be the
first dude to dog her out
what
he's 45 so he's pretty I mean so he's
34.
Justin Bieber possessed fans hey Justin
could you please
that's r-a-p-e me and my daughter
and then hit me with a bat if I get out
of line what is that
and he has this he has a daughter right
for real
there's a real daughter he's talking
about
see this is why I erased all my tweets
is it 11 years ago he's probably totally
you know what I mean this guy's lived a
whole lifetime since he posted these but
they are hard to explain
so most of y'all saying y'all started
thinking about sex at 11 or 12. okay
cool my daughter is moving in with me at
10.
like what's the joke I'm
trying to figure that one out
what's with the daughter stuff I don't
understand yeah yeah be real fellas if
you [__] the girl and she has a daughter
that you've seen grown up would you [__]
her when she grew up
are you is he talking about [__] his
own kid also his daughters
wrote These tweets okay this one I at
least understand the question he's
saying like if you're with a girl who
has a daughter and that thought you see
that daughter grow up
would you would you [__] her while she's
growing up the premise being that of
course you want to [__] you've always
wanted to [__] her
kind of because he's saying be real
fellas
I'm saying that he would yeah he he
definitely would this is very this is
weird stuff
yeah I was kind of uh
jaw-dropping
and um
here's some other ones
he would start raining the night I want
to go out
see I don't know what that is I asked
I asked women are they [__] on
Twitter so if they try and haul a
did you go over these baby
I swear if I take it Phil
I swear if I take you to Philippine and
you're telling me I can legally
the Felipe
you're looking forward yeah that's what
I think I'm gonna say it again women
Never Say Never especially since the
invention of the date r word drug
I don't even know what you're wild as
[__] dude
yeah so there it is little Duval 12
years ago
it's an old-timey joke
you know hey who here wants to [__] my
daughter
an old-timey kind of tale oh work with
me I tell you what I you kids start
thinking about sex around 11 12. that
means my daughter that little [__] is
moving in with me at 10. work with me
that's right
hey that one I didn't understand what
was he trying to say I think he's saying
that he wants to
keep an eye on her so she doesn't have
sex
um
at 10. oh the one of she's moving in at
10. I kind of oh maybe you think he was
talking so much about [__] his
daughter that I just assumed he was like
oh if she starts thinking about it at 13
then she should come here at 10 and then
13 it's not too far away but ew that
camp that's too obscene I mean they were
all upset yellem Shredder foreign
hit me with the old-timey
hey Justin Bieber why don't you come
rape my daughter
that's what he tweeted hit me with the
laugh track Zach
it's all time you know hey Justin Bieber
come have your way with my 10 year old
daughter work with me
it's all time people are too sensitive
these days
I don't know if you even want to have
the sound bite of you saying it
work with me at least there's old timey
music playing so they'll understand it's
all tiny like that all right
yeah not even Jimmy Lee would say this
kind of [__] all right I'm going back to
the green screen
[Music]
are you guys are getting
all right here we go I mean this it's
like work it's like better than nothing
that's good yeah it's good it's not bad
work with me
oh play give me a chestnuts or something
so close to the walls I just try not cut
off my feet okay is that the whole frame
that I'm seeing yeah yeah
cheers
[Music]
all right what should I do let's do the
fighting stuff do some default stuff
yeah
or maybe it's like this should it be
sideways or like this yeah that looks
good
foreign
nice
little Hadouken
just kick him kick him yeah okay boom
wow
powerful stuff
oh you gotta run you gotta run
it's coming for you run towards the
camera dude they're right behind you
[Laughter]
okay
maybe just back up while being scared
ah
why don't you admire the beauty of your
surroundings right now look around you
and just take it all in
oh
this is where am I
where am I
this is beautiful
oh my God
I'm speechless oh look at that car why
don't you go for a drive in it
hey watch where you're going learn to
drive you [__] old dumb [__]
okay I'm a little heavy there I think
face face more towards the camera for
something like that like yeah there you
go
hey Granny get off the road you old hag
I got a gun
don't [__] with me I got a gun in my
glove box
get the [__] out of the way
maybe you're acting suspicious you're
hiding from someone hiding from
something maybe you don't want to take
accountability I have nothing to do with
that don't pin this on me something like
that what about Tate just got into
prison you're playing Tate I can do that
one wait hold on to that Olivia
sorry I'm gonna do that one day
Hey listen
I got nothing to do with that you
understand
hey keep me out of this
I don't know nothing about nobody
all right please
none of that thank you ah
I don't think so
washed my hands no thank you
can you maybe get a little sexy with the
green screen maybe like rub it say God
it's so beautiful God I love her
something like that get a little Vin
Diesel with the green screen let me see
how it looks okay that works
you could just pretend to rub it you
know yeah you don't have to
oh God you're beautiful
damn girl
damn cool
okay talk to me talk to me baby
oh
damn
you look good damn okay
um
okay maybe you're like grossed out
you're gagging
I think I'm gonna be sick this is the
most disgusting thing I've ever seen
dude that's disgusting
and that's gross dude get that out of
here
Chester uh gesture behind you're more
like
you're pointing at what's behind you
yeah and so gross dude get out of here
yeah
stop dude I think we should get some
like generic
like stuff like this yep
be standing still
wait he was a t-pose for posterity yeah
it was a t-pose and then maybe an A Pose
like this yeah yep legs together very
nice
and now a pose with your arms down like
three quarters
perfect excellent you're doing great
about look at the size of that
how big that is
look at the size of that
that is enormous
I have never seen something that big
look at the size of that thing right
there a holy smokes
let's get some props going
NPC Ethan
I think this is going to reflect the
green look really good
oh yeah boy
um
yes sir
I'm out here just
fishing
yes sir caught me a big one
um
the key is so much worse since yes sir
oh caught me one time one this big
[Music]
that's right
yes sir pretend to reeling a big one
dude
oh can someone pull it yeah
let's see
you guys can just edit out AV
if you step closer to me I'll be out of
it
okay pull it down pull it down real hard
oh that's a big one
another
boy
come on now come on oh man okay
okay
going to war
thank you
I'm trying not to say things they're
gonna work at all it's all kid out oh
yeah
I mean it's better than nothing I guess
I mean just we have lots of other ones
that aren't the same colors
well oh I guess the yellow is too close
yeah
um
the hat is too tall
I Gotta Get Low I tell you what man
Trump is the best President we ever had
he's still president but I tell you what
that Joe Biden been resurrected some
kind of robot
he ain't right
Trump number one president
look at this look what Trump has done
for us what has Joe Biden Brandon done
for us like this here
look at all this good stuff that Donald
Trump has done for you you ungrateful
okay
okay this one
I guess it's better yeah
is there something in that no no
stop right there bucko
hey
you want to see the business end of a
Nerf gun you better back up bucko
yo pull your hands up
put your hands up I'm not gonna ask you
again
yo submit
yo put your hands up put them up
I'll kill you right now boy
FBI open up
do some Matrix bullet time
get some what Matrix uh you're avoiding
bullets right now
classic
which one were you saying oh yeah the
kicking down the door yep
open up
somebody in chat said what is this movie
whatever you want it to be
oh this is the worst episode we've ever
shot I think it's gonna produce the best
I think the content would be good yeah
maybe just a default jump without any
prop a jump yeah
make sure it's like in Prem I don't know
it's really hard to be in frame yeah
like a video game jump yeah yeah that's
good
it works and then do a little bit of
running afterwards too
jump Maybe
maybe a roll
yeah
just getting a rolling pose and somebody
can
that is awesome I don't know if it's in
screen it's good that was good all right
what about dancing
maybe you're talking to someone you come
here often
I like the way you move hey you come out
here often nice to see out here in the
club
yeah I don't see you very much I'm here
all the time
what's your name my name's Ethan nice to
meet you whoa
let's Feel The Beat just forget about
everything tonight tonight's just about
the boys
just forget about it all man just let it
go
just forget about everything
tonight's about the boys
why don't you give us some silent
meditation now
we were reaching enlightenment
sitting on yep sitting down
I think the camera's gotta go down a
little
nope
[Music]
this is good
alfredo
you're so white are you gonna key out
yeah
all right meditation yep you're becoming
one with the universe
I'm pretty keyed out here well whatever
the good ones can make it work you gotta
move it foofy
I'm doing a podcast Shredder you need
help Mom come here
are you too funny scram oh wait scream
come here you can grab them
oh Fred oh Fredo
all right deep meditation yep
um
[Music]
I can do that yeah
um
just not
on
[Music]
have some exercises
yeah you you're joining in I can feel
the burn
come on do it with us
get in on this
you should lay down on your back like
you sleep and wake up
okay
haha
okay maybe do a Superman flying pose on
the ground there what cam do a Superman
oh yeah
yeah Superman like flying pose
okay good idea
come here shred come back pretty I guess
I should do it yeah
all this stuff on the floors the key is
pretty awful well the good ones can make
it work you know I think so too yeah I'm
trying to do a podcast Bobby that's not
gonna be perfect yeah
okay that Mom please
just someone just better come grab them
better shots saying um do the Fouseytube
speech
okay hold on hold on to that
okay it's really good yeah front
let's see you got to put it down a
little bit
foreign
speech
oh FouseyTUBE
yeah hell no yeah
uh the next other ones on the list uh
King hat
um chef hat and jacket
those are some props over there I think
the king's hat let's go yeah I think
this one's gonna key out completely it's
very reflective but let's see
that's not very good I mean just take if
you stand up I can zoom into you'll be
better
okay
oh somebody Joseph said pretend you're
underwater oh that's really good
by Royal Decree I do declare
that I shall bet every female before her
day of marriage
by Royal declare I do declare
what do I declare you guys
I declare execute him
I have decided
execute him
I have decided remove his head
oh The Peasants are such a The Peasants
are so Troublesome I'm telling you
I wish I could just wipe out the whole
world of these peasants and turn them
into glue
just tell them Jesus said for me to do
it it'll get us out of everything
Jesus told me to do it what can I do
okay next
um the chef hat and jacket
saying someone cooked here or let him
cook and point behind you yeah
also pretend like you're eating
something tasty
I like that
like it
let me suit up Chef Boyardee over here
yeah
it's a little tight but that's what we
like it I'm a well-fed chef
the goods a good sign of any chef
I don't know about you guys but I like a
chef that likes to eat
you know what I'm saying
all right ready
this guy over here is cooked
I'll take my steak well done oh my God
how cooked can you be dude
this guy is flame broiled he is done
cooked
like Chester and be like okay guys let
let him cook just let him cook
just let them cook
he did this to himself
just let him cook
she ate and left no crumbs
say that she ate she ate and left no
crumbs
we love a sassy aquarium what is that
like so saying yeah it means like she
slayed she slayed super hard girl you
slayed so hard you didn't leave any
crumbs and to me that's a chef's dream
yeah I loved it
you eat and don't leave any she ate and
didn't leave any crumbs and then she
also slays at the same time but not
together like two distinct actions the
slaying
girl as the executive chef of this
restaurant I would like to inform you
that you slayed
no it's
probably be more appropriate for the
girl you slayed the the eating and
leaving no crumbs girl you slayed that
fits more with the chef theme girl you
ate and left no crumbs yes girl you
slayed all right well give me a shot you
guys this is my show go let him cook let
him cook let this man cook girl you
slayed
and then we took the body and we chopped
It Up made a delicious meal and then you
ate and left no crumbs that's you
that was good girl you ate and left no
crumbs
bro you are my favorite type of customer
you don't leave any crumbs
what we got some tea
I'm like looking back look back at the
green screen take a sip and laugh
foreign
at you at Hell's Kitchen
I'm sorry Mr Ramsey please I'll do
better I'll do better please I'm sorry
Mr Ramsey
please please don't yell at me
foreign
I hope people make ratatouille edits for
sure I'll do one of these
perfect
okay
um and being a news anchor could be one
thing so let me okay I'm retiring the
chef's hats
when you do stuff like the ti maybe you
don't even need like a prop you can just
fake drinks people will add it
oh
I want to do one like the uh the Ruffles
guy
you flip the bag yeah turn around
yeah
that's a good one
[Music]
I can't see my feet is that okay
they can just superimpose shoes on
I'm in the top of my head's cut off
here
maybe oh hit the gritty somebody said
hit the gritty
yeah we need some fortnite dances
okay I like that
that shit's Wild
you want my
yeah right
whatever
what about this
real good
oh we didn't running away from like if
you run
run and look in Look Backwards does that
make sense or like a Subway Surfer yeah
so I need the whole body again
yeah so look the other way I guess I
don't know we did that we didn't do the
other way facing the green screen oh
like this right yeah
maybe look back yeah
okay now I can do Subway Surfer content
with you in it
that's awesome thank you
all right Wonder water
Ethan starring in the new Little Mermaid
movie
uh
-huh
this is a good one from Caitlyn pretend
to smell a pie and pretend like you're
floating
[Music]
oh
foreign
I'm here to slaughter the children
die youngling
[__] these kids Mike
okay
God there's a lot of footage for these
good animals
I tell you what boy don't be coming on
my property again you hear me
if I catch you out here on my property
again we're going to have a problem boy
someone said housewife intro
yeah you do your housewife intro
oh good or pretend you're a weather man
weatherman's good
welcome everybody happy Tuesday we got a
warm system coming in which means hot
weather all around the Midwest coming in
all the weekend there's gonna be
drizzles so we want to stay warm go out
with our umbrellas only anyway I want to
give a shout out to my wife Chelsea who
[__] my cousin over the weekend [__]
now my whole life is raining and it's
your fault I hope you [__] die
anyway coming in over the weekend nice
beautiful weather
clouds are going to be passing by no
rain
what was the other one
okay what was everyone wait wait before
you move on past the weatherman you're
you're Al Roker in the hurricane
oh good
yes
the winds are quite strong it's a it's a
category 5 hurricane
I don't know why I'm out here why do you
guys keep doing this to me
there's no weather value
to me being out here it's just dangerous
for no reason
why do you hate me I'm just the weather
guy
that's just the weather guy ah yeah
yeah okay
vinyl chloride I like that
is anyone still watching
the viewers have dropped quite a bit I
will admit yeah I understand that
one wait I got one first
I love the smell of vinyl chloride in
the morning oh we
um you smell that
nothing like the smell of claw
I think it's that's too specific
um
I love me some toxic fumes in the
morning
give me water
this fresh water yes
tastes better with all the chemicals in
it
um
this train crash been the best thing
that ever happened in this town
um
this water never tasted better
my wife just had a miscarriage but this
water never tasted better
um
my wife was just diagnosed with thyroid
cancer but this water ain't never tasted
better
I [__] out blood this morning but
this water
never tasted better
cheers
um
there's blood coming out my nipples
but this water never tasted better
[Music]
I'll do a spectacular
um
what else is there I want to wrap this
up
this is just dancing
maybe do a greedy
oh the gritty yeah you gotta hit the
gritty come on I'm not even sure how to
do the greeting
it's just like what makes it good yeah
we might have to zoom out for that you
do like this right
yes yep
give us a profile of you sheesh
turn to the side
there we go
hit that pretty boy
hit that gritty nice and low
whoa oh
I am done
and seeing
that was the cherry on top good job
sorry about that guys I was truly
some of the worst live content you could
ever ask for
but that's part of the specialness of
the show you know
we experiment but it's gonna make some
of the best content the show's seen too
from the viewers I hope so I hope so too
sometimes you go to McDonald's moment
and sometimes you get this
that's the that's what experimentation
is a lot of people enjoyed it
we'll do it live
did I get all the important ones you
guys think
you uh hit the whole list I think oh I
see the preacher one but and whatever
whatever this goal is against God
dude I'm in a Schmitz bro that was a lot
what the [__]
I was hitting that water for real
um
I was hitting that water
Lily chug in the water oh
all right is what else we got here
we got Darman update okay yeah we should
put a deadline Kim how long do you think
people need to edit this
um
does two weeks sound fair I don't know
more than I think that's a lot like next
Friday next Friday okay yeah next Friday
yeah that's good
oh we have a guest next Friday
can you type it to me
apparently we have a nice guest thanks
Ryder oh I know who it is we know wait
why can't we say it
because she's afraid I asked just to be
sure and she said next week
but she's specific specifically said
don't say it publicly well last time we
there was a little confusion about it
when you said can I say it so I just
wanted to be sure so I asked and she
said she would rather us do it next week
oh I know that
I can't say it right she would rather us
announce it next week announce it wait
she's coming on next week yeah so
announce it when she's on no no no like
Monday I don't want to wait till Monday
I don't know what to tell you all right
I'll wait yeah so then we could do it um
on Monday or we could do it on Wednesday
Wednesday might not be enough time
so maybe let's say two weeks two weeks
yeah two weeks and Friday get to work
y'all there's big money on the line cool
I'll tell you who doesn't believe in big
money yeah Darman
[Music]
you know about Dar Manila wow so what
the heck he makes these
uh people make excuses for him they say
it's for non-english speakers it's weird
and bad and just [__] weird content
dude he makes like inspirational
stories that are super cheesy and the
moral is like super reductive and just
so stupid I'll show you an example
somebody put me in front of the twin
Towners you guys seriously I have a few
people have show it to me
that's not cool you guys
nothing that embarrasses me you
understand I forgot to mention that at
the top nobody used these to embarrass
me you need my written approval before
you publish anything to the internet you
understand now you're living
I want to see the 911. that is pretty
fun
oh my God you guys are [__] tasty
right there how dare you how dare you
you monsters
some further information hi there I'm
Ethan Klein you know in today's society
people go through a lot of hard times I
mean take a look at these guys here it's
really been a tough time but I'm here
with the Miracle Solution this is going
to change how you see everything oh God
join me on this journey
wow this is dangerous hey guys you know
what DMC is that damn they don't have my
permission
okay
that's illegal you got it I'll get it
right on that I'm that picture is so
cursed oh God yeah I feel like I just
gotta oh no you guys did not you guys
are just
no shame strike the 911.
well that is frankly a an accurate face
to make I mean at the at the such a
tragedy
be a good thumbnail possibly
some people put you in the prolapse
already that I saw coming
someone with me looking around being
like this is beautiful
well you guys are already coming huh
Sasquatch
[Laughter]
because they're fast at work y'all
love me set we're gonna discover some
Mega talents out of this I feel like
you know
I hate spiders
[Music]
that was just how you guys said I hate
spiders oh we sat down at the same time
like at the same time
that's what love is I hope you guys find
that one day 10 years of marriage
that's what it looks like
that's right
okay so Darman I'll show you an example
okay he it TR you might remember him
because Trisha was making these like
inspirational videos and she was copying
him I don't remember those no or like
Moses was like Hey I used to be
I used to work in a movie and you
thought I was poor but now you found out
I'm rich and now you want to date me you
don't remember those
yeah okay so fine I'll pull up one for
you
foreign
bodyguard seduces rich wife
tell me which one catches your eye
problem kid tries to get future fired
wife demands divorce on Valentine's how
could she
man hide's second child from life like
what's the moral of that I know that's
not don't do that
the a guys I just want to let you know
starting a second family in secret is
something you should never do
yes so what is it I guess show me what
does he do I'm trying to find the
dumbest possible
I mean the hiding the second child is
pretty good yeah that's it's
so he pumps out content he does one of
these every day and he works with a ton
of actors now when I first heard about
Donald he actually has a lot of views on
this dude a lot what he's watching it I
that's that is one of the greatest
YouTube Mysteries to me what and I I
think we determined that the YouTube
views are dwarfed by the Facebook views
oh on Facebook this [__] gets like 100
million yeah this is what this one's
three million three days ago the same
video on Facebook's probably like 10.
I'm genuinely curious who's what I know
you guys said that it's popular with
non-english that's not the main bulk of
who's watching this who the [__] is
watching yeah I thought that it was
going to be like some kind of
underground meme like thousand views no
he's for real so he has this huge
production company
now the first thing I heard is Brian or
my brother-in-law
was working with a child actor who
worked for Darman
um and he was telling bro my my
brother-in-law about the job you
remember that right yeah I didn't know
that that's what it was about and he
would pay him like minimum wage and the
kid had to drive there from Ventura to
LA and he was basically losing money to
do it because he thought it was like a
great opportunity but he was clearly
taking crazy advantage over this child
who there's no protection laws in
traditional media you can't hire a kid
without meeting certain criteria you
have to provide for them so he doesn't
do anything like that he pays him dog
[__] wage and um
and he making a [__] ton of money hmm
uh so here here let's let's take a look
that is because you always cheat
just like your father
look what you had trained our son to do
[Music]
hello
Earth was that a joke or oh my God this
is wild already this guy was in Vietnam
or something yeah that's that's not a
cheating stare that's like a flashback
Todd
what what are we talking about talking
about how you've trained our son to
cheat you should smell that you never
win mom I'm going to get it are you
gonna fix this bro
I did the right thing I started a family
with another woman in secret
and I did the right thing I killed the
second family and forgot all about them
either I'll end up on Dateline or
happily married
I really feel his pain you know
hey is everything okay
been pretty quiet the last few days yeah
no I'm fine I I just um
I need to talk to you about something
important well
okay after this game what's up
um I don't
I don't really know how to
say this but um dance you say after this
acting you understand why he doesn't pay
them but no they direct them to do this
every video but I mean it does seem like
minimum wage would be kind of
appropriate no I mean it's not like well
no so so the other thing is they do long
day they do like full like 12-hour days
and they have to stay on set yeah yeah I
hear you though but some of these actors
have been working with I don't know I
don't know it's not like we know I was
just being a [__] I'm a hearing sorry I
mean I guess at the end of the day you
are kind of right it's like it's just
that minimum job he is taking minimum
wage whatever job well Leslie keep them
there longer until they get it right
I
just needed proof yeah somebody said
minimum wage minimum effort you're
getting like you get what you pay for it
too yeah I know that's funny but it's
really not true he has them on
professional sets
let's not get carried away we don't know
what goes on no he does we know no we
know a little bit he has two
no no they went out there was protesters
outside of Studio the actors went on
strike and were protesting yeah
I thought you're still talking about
what Brian said no no no no I only
explain yourself yeah I only remembered
what Brian said after the story broke
so last week actors and workers at
Darman Studio started protesting for
better wages and treatments while
working with the company this guy made a
five minute long Tick-Tock video about
it an actor of his were just so [__]
boring we had to do a Subway Surfer
kinetic sand caught knife and Subway
Surfer to make it palatable did I say
Subway Surfer already yeah yeah you did
but there may have been two it could
have been since Subway Surfer on the
screen I think we were also playing
Brown noise
uh yeah I think it was whale cars so so
I I actually don't even know what he
said but it was kind of boring but
basically he said it was it wasn't nice
to them right didn't pay them good yeah
that they can't make a living doing with
what he pays them basically no but the
expectation he puts on them is like 12
hour days
this is a full professional studio
and he's making a shitload of money so
you know whatever
but here is he responded to all the
drama and that's what this is about
um
first he made a tick tock
with that with the remaining actors and
I was thinking I hope he paid them to
hit their day rate for this like this
looks like it was just another gig I
think all right guys we're shooting in
another inspirational video it's about a
guy who's down on his luck and
everyone's there to support him watch
this foreign
[Music]
what's the song he's playing We Are
Family We Are Family yeah
dude these are the actors who were not
protesting the scabs
[Music]
so here's like a multi-millionaire
basking in the love of these peasant
actors
[Laughter]
so that was his response actually he has
more but I thought that was so [__]
weird bro but it's it's right in his
style it's the Darman style comments are
off
[Music]
amen thank you bro
thank you so are you paying us for today
or what
for sure this was like a gig for them
[Music]
okay I need you guys to come in early
and just shoot this Tick Tock with me
for free about how cool I am they
definitely got a day rape yeah
I think they're at gunpoint off off
screen there's there are five with AKs
right off the frame yeah that's possible
we can't ignore that possibility
uh it's it's rumored that the last actor
that tried to protest was beheaded on a
second Channel
um
thank you Zach
he also made a post
on Instagram
but I thought we put it into this nice
collage just to kind of
it was giving me just kind of a feeling
of you know Kim Jong-un everyone's happy
to see him there this is the Mormon sex
cult guy look how happy they all are a
good time and then who's this guy Jim
Jones that's Jim Jones Jim Jones I mean
look out look at the genuine Smiles of
love and affection they all have for
their dear leader yeah so you know right
on right on the nose there
yeah so he posted to Instagram
here here's one more example of like a
yeah that's a cult that's not funny all
centered around one person that's
actually keeps taking his shirt off at
inappropriate times yeah that's not
funny don't laugh look how big my hand
looks on my
zoom in on my hand not that one yeah the
other one nice clap
dude look how [__] massive my hand
looks please clap
look at that ugly mug dude only a Monica
love staring at the hand I'm so
impressed it's the whole size of your
whole damn face bro
you got a small head or what
look at that hand doesn't look that big
I respect this that hand doesn't
actually look that big to me
okay now you're just hating and you're
trying to hurt my feelings
don't appreciate that look whose hand is
this
it's almost the same size and they're
like way behind you like zoom in on it
why you okay first of all Lena
it's way more petite than my hand first
of all
and she's not that far behind me
Lena are you comfortable with Dan
calling you big hands no no she has
regular size hands and I'm saying I
think she's early that's okay hey Dan
She's a beauty queen I'll have you know
yeah I understand with stunning long
fingers hey Dan thank you Olivia keep my
wife's name
[Laughter]
but I do think Lena has bigger hands
than you just stick hands eye out you
think she has bigger hands bring them
out here
Ethan you don't want to do bring those
hands up
well yeah so we don't have to do this
Dan who thought it would be cool to body
shame you
dance she's piano playing him I think
she just doesn't want to make you feel
better I'm not embarrassed I'm not
committing to going hand to hand I just
want to see first of all visually and
then I'll decide if I want to show him
what's up yeah I just want to see you
okay I'm coming yeah just come here
okay it took me forever to find this
post but it's funny because we do sort
of have a Darman
here stand right here you can see
let me see
take a look at this and tell me if I
should go to Indiana that's a bad idea
it's pretty similar Maybe
[Music]
left my left hand seems bigger right
now
let's line up there a little bit
[Laughter]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
is sweating after that one
all right let's talk about how shitty
Darman is get off me for a minute
yeah so here's his Instagram post
thank God
so here he is once again with his family
that works uh
for 12 an hour
the past week has been a roller coaster
of emotions he said I'm saddened for
those affected by everything going on
for the various misleading stories that
have spread
what does he mean by those affected
probably everybody that works with him
the doggies okay
I just met with some great actors who
have been with us from the beginning
we're all doing our best to get through
this together and respectful and
positive way it's like you're they're
not going through it with you no they
did they're not included right this is
about you Darman
also you know he never meets with the
actors he goes I just met with some
great actors
but doesn't he say as much in like on
the next slide he does yeah he does
for those that don't know there have
been recent protests at our studio by a
group of actors many of whom we have not
worked with in years what we tried to
fact check that were we able to I this I
can't tell I have a hard time thinking
I'm skeptical of this whole statement
well he said something coming up about
how much he pays them that I feel like
can be very easily proven or disproven
so that should give us some more
information so he says these protesters
represent a small percentage of the
Thousand bro a thousand actors you need
to be regulated thousands
thousands like hello this is [__]
he's doing a legit Production Studio
with none of the Union none of the
regulations thousands bro
with children by the way these
protesters represent a small percentage
of the thousands of actors we have and
do not resent the views of all actors
well nothing does
I could say everyone I know hates your
videos
clearly it's not everybody in the world
wish it was the processors have said
that I won't meet with actors and do not
show up for a planned meeting they said
that they want to have like a
negotiation with him and that he won't
do it he wouldn't show up to talk to
them he's stiff again and just made him
talk to like HR he kept giving them the
run around ship before they went public
they said
he says that's not true I love meeting
with actors
and talking to them whenever I'm at the
studio
that's like this I love meeting with
actors
I'm sure and talking to them whenever
I'm at the studio for example when I
pass they are not allowed to look at me
in the eye but they can say hello
but if there's ever a formal meeting
request from an actor the meeting
usually starts with our head of
production or our HR manager not me
personally that's what they said
but just to show you how Corporate this
[__] is
he's like yeah no I can't meet with you
you need to go through HR
come on bro
when the protesters requested a meeting
it was scheduled with our management
team
it was never communicated that I would
attend during that meeting the
protesters did not communicate any
concerns and instead walked out within a
few minutes
that's not that can't be true they just
came in and they just gave up stink eye
and they were they spit on the ground
they cut they dumped over our trash cans
and left
they never asked for anything I hear
chewing yeah I mean I think that that
actually you have food out because I
think he's oh it's a food okay cool yeah
I think that that actually does line up
with um
the report from the gentleman whose
video we talked and played sounds yeah
the entire time yeah he said they had
this meeting and they hadn't set up the
meeting to confront Darman and he didn't
show up and so they said he needs to
come or we're leaving
and and they left so I that does line up
with what Darman is now saying dude
Darman is a is a is a criminal the 2013
man was convicted of defrauding the city
of Oakland
through his real estate company man Edge
probably no any details on that what
okay that to me is a huge red flag
this man breaded his butter by scamming
Oakland City
dharminder man dharmender yeah I think
that's just his fault what that's him
what a funny plot twist wait this is
from 2012. this is pretty Darman
and they it was so egregious they wrote
an article about it sfgate.com
wow new Darman lore just dropped holy
[__] hey I got an idea for your next
video man defraud's entire city scam bro
did he go to jail where her house damn
he has a prominent family I think it was
just probation probation leading face of
the medical marijuana industry let's go
huh
in reality you guys got scammed also he
it seems like he's well connected which
got him off
that has cultivated close ties to city
councilwoman desily Brooks 2010 he
opened a school University of cannabis
are you [__] kidding me University of
cannabis
he opened a school that's what I'm
talking about called University of
cannabis I'm [__] enrolling tomorrow
baby
Dan you want to be my study buddy yeah
let's let's get let's get let's get
roomies in the dorm amen we've got a man
on the phone oh credential tenured
professors at University what did Best
Buy why am I talking about enrolling I
need to be a professor hey Dan School
let's get 10 years
what's the optimal temperature to hit a
vape at hey Dan you gonna be enrolling
later
maybe all of his actors are like his old
customers
um let me make sure that this was not
retracted like a certain other article
before we go any further yeah I'm seeing
I'm seeing the editor's notes on a few
articles saying that he paid the fine
and was released early from probation so
okay so I mean there's no Contra you
paid the fine uh he did the crime he
paid the fine you know it's all good
we we believe in rehabilitation in this
house that was the crime that's crazy
though because he okay so there you go
he's not this I mean that's not
saint-like Behavior
by the way it's 4 20 right now dude
recess man everybody to the playground
[Music]
420 every day
sorry a little racist
is it yeah for sure
I mean you just shouldn't let's do a
fake Jamaican accent in general for some
reason that feels less offensive because
everybody gets in on that
you know what I mean so I'm just I'm
just a Rastafarian Dan I don't think you
are I'm just I'm not doing a Jamaican
impression I'm doing a Chet Hank's
impression day all right it's meta yeah
sorry to all the Jamaicans out there who
are fuming
they're too high on marijuana even okay
that is racist right right that's
actually way more racist than doing the
accent yeah that was too far yeah
given the unsuccessful meetings we asked
they put their concerns in writing so we
could address them instead they came to
our studio to disrupt Productions
causing stress to crew members and
actors
yeah I'm sure they were really stressed
out
certain protesters even spread false
information or hurt the studio my family
and me that's the reason why I have not
met with these individuals
I thought you already passed before any
of that happened
I would also like to address the
misinformation being spread by
protesters that we don't pay our actors
okay
this is one first of all nobody claimed
that
nobody claimed he doesn't pay them
that's kind of a little trick he played
there this is 100 not sure we always pay
actors for any work they perform
including tick tocks where they pretend
to like me
we don't have any full-time actors we
offer project-based opportunities this
is a standard practice in the production
and acting industry
all details including pay rate and
length of production are specified in
the offer letter and the actor has
freedom to accept or decline the project
if accepted actors are paid within 72
hours after a production wraps are
current I mean that's such a why are you
even making that point we don't force
them at gunpoint to work for us yeah
like yeah no of course not yeah it's
dummy it's really scummy they could say
no
right that's not really the point yeah
not if accepted they just they want
better wages it's just like a protest
you know what I mean like yeah we're
pro-union around here that's right it's
not for you guys
yeah it sounds like his whole statement
is just kind of like
rewarded in a way that
for Dum Dums which sounds good it's
bright if accepted actors are paid
within 72 hours after production and
then he says our current rate for actors
was speaking roles are 33 to 44 now
that's not bad but he says our current
rate so I would like to know and
actually lose weight speaking rules
with a little bit of weasel weasel word
there current current rate yeah yeah but
that was the part that I was referring
to earlier that is so easily proven or
disproven just one of the actors that
are protesting just show a pay stub
that's what I want I want someone yeah
because what's let's say 33
because by 33 to 44 he means 33. right
so what's 33 times uh eight
crunch those numbers for me
264. but you know with acting it's
generally generally understood that it's
gonna be a 10 hour day uh which is
technically two hours of OT uh at time
and a half so it'll be eight hours at
33.
uh so that's the 363 a day I feel like
there's no way he's paying them that
which still isn't a ton of money but did
we try reaching out to the sky I wanna I
Wanna Get the facts
the guy on tick tock I bet he'd talk to
us I can yeah all right I want to see a
pay stub let's just end this right now
the man we called so boring yeah yeah I
don't know I'm here listen I wasn't
checked out the video he might not I'm
on his side he's just not great at
making videos you know it's a skill you
can get better right
I'm sympathetic but [__] that was a
boring video
yeah reach out to him
it means that it doesn't mean I don't
like him as a person
he just yeah he's just not used to he's
not a content creator as I said in two
and a half years working here that was
the hardest video I had to watch
Greta Jane says the actor said they get
uh they get paid only two hours of the
day I mean whoa yeah again it's what
two hours I'm leaning towards uh him
being full of [__] but it's just by by
actually giving a firm statement about
how much he pays that makes it very easy
to work out whether or not
uh he's talking if he was really paying
people 300 plus per day right I don't
think there'd be any problems yeah
exactly yeah I don't think there would
be paying for two hours doesn't make
sense yes
so he says uh while I'm taking the steps
stop the spread of misinformation he's
implying he's going to sue them I think
Logan Paul style I do acknowledge that
there's always opportunity for me to
grow oh thank you so today in my meeting
with actors oh he met with the actors
these are the nice ones by the way we
came up with ways to improve such thing
as more efficient booking system [__]
they want more money
stronger Communications and more
consistent hours and pay
these changes are now in motion
so the protests worked I don't know what
that means
my mission on why I started this channel
has always been to spread positivity
anyway yeah after I defrauded this the
the city of Oakland I wanted to make
this channel to spread positivity
after writing fake checks
and defrauding the city of Oakland I
really wanted to spread some love
although this has been a challenging
time I'm never going to stop working
hard towards that goal I do ask to
please stop with any negative comments
especially towards actors regardless of
their views or I don't care about the
actors
I mean I do I want the best for them
I'm so thankful for all the love and
support Dar man
I gotta know we gotta get to the bottom
of this
yeah well Olivia will reach out
um to our friend friend of the show
um and best friend we love his content
we love everything he does yeah again
it's just like with without putting that
information out there it makes it very
easy to confirm her tonight first of all
he's sitting with Jay Shetty so there's
your first strike yeah so they do have a
podcast together
dude I'm telling you the [__] rats
they congregate they attract each other
where uh
I know where Jay Shetty got that 20
smoothie idea from
he's got a like a Fouseytube beard line
going
looks artificial doesn't it
oh but yeah
it's probably just lined up he's just
lined up you think he's just lined up
yeah I want to hear what they're saying
I want to hear if it's interesting or if
it makes me hate them more
bottom right corner you did in the
bottom right corner oh [__] by being the
bigger person I'm carrying that with me
now for sure for the rest of my life
when that person is gonna stay stagnant
in their place when we in our most
vulnerable moments could admit that we
could have done something better it's
not that the other person dude you just
had the opportunity to do that
this is from 12 weeks ago okay so before
the concert yeah but he prophesized that
he would not rise to the occasions right
it's that you win right because
ultimately you're becoming the better
version of yourself that you want to be
not every relationship is meant to last
forever some people are only going to be
in your life temporarily right and that
like my actors for example they come and
they go all right that's okay but if I I
don't care
because they're boring
not funny at all Darman is like the
least funny person that's all I care
about
all right well let's wrap it up thank
you guys
that was an interesting episode I can't
say it was a great episode
but it was an episode I mean we had fun
the green screen thing you know I know
isn't the most thrilling content in the
moment but you know we're planting seeds
we're gonna we're gonna reap the bounty
in the near future here dude I'm so wet
from that
that was a lot
oh did we ever physical effort we
reached out to Jordan Peterson right
did you send the email no let's talk
about after the show about the Jordan
stuff did you send the email no
you didn't send an email
[Laughter]
that's straight up uh what do you call
it in the Army when they don't follow
orders
insubordination that's straight up
insubordinate
you're going to be disciplined bro yeah
[Music]
I will drop you off at the next dock do
you understand me
Sandy uh represents people you will be
fired so fast
I will drop you off at the next Dock and
you'll be flying home
I will not tolerate Mutiny on this ship
that is not how you talk to your captain
[Music]
we are the children
did we have we had another 10 gifts that
I don't think
[Music]
thank you Adam campius
and a lame Christian thank you gifted
Legends
first second your heart
all right you can just just play us out
Dan or Zach
but then I'll Helping Hands
feel all the children
will make it Brotherhood there so I
started